[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've had my heart broken
into it
[Music]
but something's different next to you
[Music]
it's like my soul is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
feelings that i know
[Music]
i can't keep on this road alone
[Music]
[Music]
that
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
then
feelings
[Music]
feelings
[Music]
that i know i can't keep bottled up
inside
and all i wanna know is are you ready
for the ride
what have i been waiting for oh i can
run but i can't hide
the feelings that i know
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know
[Music]
living in the light you're giving out
[Music]
whenever you cross my mind
[Music]
without your baby
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
let you i'm
stay
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
nobody
[Music]
all this is
[Music]
know
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
we're flying high like a
[Music]
when you're with me and i realize what
it all means
[Music]
you're the one on my
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
till the sky
[Music]
of this feeling
soaking in your light right above me
it's an open sky full of dreams
[Music]
is
[Music]
every single crowd and i know you love
me
till the sky
[Music]
i was running
to the ocean
[Music]
[Music]
underneath
[Music]
i was doing just
[Music]
[Music]
for me
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
for me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome to recipe for an
accessible component i'm sophia a front
end engineer at course hero
i'm here with karen a senior friend an
engineer also from course here so i
actually have a question for you sophia
when people
think about accessibility
what do you think that most people
have in mind
i think that people tend to think of
very visible disabilities
so when we think about like
visual symbolism it's the person in the
wheelchair
it's a person with a crutch
but i think when we think about
accessibility in a more universal sense
it becomes
uh kind of more motivating so this
definition which was kind of cobbled
together from a bunch of different
definitions says
that websites that are designed and
developed so that every person can
understand navigate and contribute to
them no matter their device their
circumstances
or their ability i think that definition
of web accessibility makes us realize
that it's more of a universal thing
right so maybe you don't have a
conventional disability
but a website that has high contrast and
clear information structure is easier to
understand when you're on your phone or
maybe if you're in a really loud
environment
right you really want those captions
even if you can hear in normal
circumstances one thing that's
interesting to know is that
disability affects a lot more people
than people realize so
according to the cdc
roughly about 15 of the people in the
world have some form of disability but
that number goes to roughly one to five
when you look at adults specifically
and there's four major kinds there's
manual or motor mobility which means
that maybe the user
can't
operate a mouse the same way that other
people can
um there's hearing disabilities in which
case captions are really important and
then there's like different levels of
visual disability right it might not
mean that the person
is completely unable to see but maybe
they need to use the zoom
function or maybe they need higher
contrast and then there's also cognitive
disability which means that they really
are relying on a really clear
information hierarchy to understand
where they're going and what they're
doing on the website
so to summarize why is it important
one better accessibility on the web
benefits everyone
again with the example of high contrast
captions like a lot of people will
benefit from that even if they don't
have a conventional disability
and then it's also the law right so the
americans with disabilities act
has spurred a lot of these lawsuits
related to companies missing certain
features on their websites so hulu faced
a lawsuit in 2017
because they didn't have caption support
for a lot of their videos beyonce's
website also had its own lawsuit because
the website is kind of like a visual
photo diary but it was missing a lot of
the text alternatives and the keyboard
navigation that a lot of people rely on
so
it's kind of interesting to think about
accessibility and react
there was a study that was done earlier
this year by webbing which is
an organization
that
is considered an authority on web
accessibility and
in their study they looked at the top 1
million websites and what technologies
they use and how those
choices affected accessibility and one
category was frameworks and they found
that pages that use react had about six
percent more
accessibility errors in the average
website
but this is completely preventable right
there's nothing inherent to react that
prevents us from building accessible
components and websites so
we're gonna talk about how to do that by
doing a demo for how to build an
accessible accordion
all right here we are on localhost with
a really basic accordion we've set up
so so tell me a little bit about what
you mean when you're saying an accordion
here
that's a great question so there's a lot
of names for it um
sometimes it's called a collapsible
section sometimes it's called called a
drop down but basically it's just
a button that lets you toggle content by
clicking on it so let's think about the
accessibility of this one really
great built-in tool that's on chrome is
lighthouse
so that's something in dev tools that
you can use to evaluate
your website for things like seo
accessibility and also just general
performance
so
let's open up dev tools i'm gonna go to
the lighthouse
option and then we're just gonna have
accessibility checked off
and we're gonna run it by clicking
generate report
see what it says okay
it's not too bad but there's an issue
that's flagged which is contrast so it
says background and foreground colors
do not have a sufficient contrast ratio
all right so let's let's see
what that ratio is
and i can see the
the problematic element is accordion
title
uh so let's select that
all right it's telling me the contrast
ratio is
1.97
which is
not great it doesn't pass even the
minimum requirement so
we will want to fix that okay
you know one thing i did notice is this
additional items to manually check can
we take a quick look at that sure what
it says there
uh page has a logical tab order
interactive keyboard controls let's see
tabbing through the page
keyboard controls i don't think we set
this up on our example let's uh
take a look here
tabbing doesn't do anything
when i see something like this the page
that actually comes to mind is one of my
favorite resources the w3c um these aria
design patterns uh let's uh command f
here and see if we can find uh an
accordion ah there we are
okay so this has a little example
accordion it works pretty similar to
ours um i notice uh already some
differences in things that are
highlighted um but let's look at the
accessibility features that chrome was
mentioning like keyboard support uh
space or enter should open things
i like these arrow options uh the tab
should be there for sure
um what else is there there's some aria
information here
uh
i like this idea of showing whether it's
expanded um there's some really good
stuff in here
uh cool so this this kind of gives us a
little idea of uh what we can focus on
going forward
all right so let's edit the code for our
accordion by hopping here in code
sandbox which is an online editor
so just to summarize some of the issues
we've noted there's the color contrast
issues there's lack of keyboard
navigation
it's uh the the ui for focus states and
then some aria attributes
so let's just walk through this quickly
we have our root component app.js which
remembers an accordion
which takes in a children
which is just an array of data objects
the individual accordions are here in
accordion item
and each according item contains a
header and a body so the header
corresponds to the text up on the button
and the body corresponds to the body
of the accordion
um so
one quick note before we start
often times in react we use a div as a
wrapper when we're returning multiple
elements
but if there isn't a better semantic
element to use or if we don't need a
class name which in this case we do then
we should use a react fragment
which
looks um like this
and the reason for doing that is we
don't
add an unnecessary
um node to the dom
which can complicate where the focus
goes in this case we do need the div
because we have a class name so we're
gonna leave that as is
um and let's tackle the first issue
which is improving the markup
so
um we're using a div for the
button here which
doesn't really say much so let's just
change that to a button element
all right so
before you panic obviously it's applying
the default styles hence why the
button's no longer full width
but not to worry we can override the
width pretty easily with a little bit of
css i'm going to hop into the style
sheet
and just
pop this here
okay we are back to where we work for
um
and again to reiterate by turning this
div into a button we can now navigate
using the tab which is very cool
another thing we should do is make it a
little more obvious that these buttons
can be clipped on
right because it's not
inherently obvious so a lot of times on
websites they'll add a plus or minus
sign plus meaning that you can expand
this section minus meaning that you can
collapse it
we are going to be a little fancy so we
are going to use the after selector to
add some triangles to our titles
um if you look in
accordion header
we have this
open class or conditionally rendering so
we can use that to show a different
triangle when it's
open versus when it's closed let's just
save this really quickly and we're going
to add
a little bit of css here
there we go now we have
upside down triangle when it is closed
and then right side up triangle when
it's open and this way it's just a
little more obvious that this is an
element that you can
interact with
so that's good um one other thing we
noticed from the lighthouse report was
that the contrast wasn't strong enough
so we can fix that very easily
we just basically need a stronger
contrast between the background color
and the text color so
just to keep it simple why don't we make
background
white and that should be
a lot better
okay
now it is a contrast ratio of 5.74
which passes from the strictest
standards with blind colors so that's
awesome
[Music]
um
one other thing is a lot of people don't
really like this default focus styling
this blue rectangle but we can customize
that and make it even pop a little more
if you
look at the
examples page they talk about how
the background color of the header
button should ideally change just to
make it more obvious that that's the one
that's open
so i'm just going to add a little
styling to the focus selector here
so now
it's a little obvious right we have this
green outline and this pale yellow color
and it's just a little bit more obvious
that
it's the element we're focused on
one other thing i want to do is add
emphasis on the header for the accordion
that's collapsed by making the text
black but right now if i
click out it actually goes back to gray
so we can
just add a little bit of css
[Music]
and this way it's a little more obvious
but it's the one that's being emphasized
awesome so we've improved some of the
things on the visual front we also want
to communicate some of this information
non-visually as well
so for example
for the average person maybe it's
obvious that the accordion is open when
you click on it but for someone who's
visually impaired we want to communicate
that information using some aria
attributes
so pretty straightforwardly we can
[Music]
apply
arya expanded to communicate whether the
toggle is open or not so we can simply
just set that to our
is open property
which will be true or false
this way
screen reader knows when it toggles open
so that's pretty straightforward um
based on the notes in the w3 site we
also want to add some attributes to
communicate the relationship between the
button and the text
right for us maybe it's obvious that you
click on the button to see the text but
for someone using screen reader we want
to communicate that otherwise so
let's add
an id
and also this aria controls property
which tells us which section
it will
compact
and then on the flip side let's also add
some attributes to accordion body
so i do roll region which just tells
screen readers hey this is not
um this doesn't fall under like a
specific type of label but it's an area
that you should read out and then also
aria labeled by
which is the inverse of aria controls
saying hey the
the um the part that points to me is
label index
so we've improved our ui to show the
focus state better we've added some
important attributes now what about that
keyboard navigation
i'm actually really excited to talk
about keyboard navigation and it's
completely vital to accessibility and as
we saw um it's actually uh there's
actually suggestions by the w3c on how
to do that so let's get started on this
let's put this together so
let's see how do we want to start here
um
i'm thinking let's start in the header
component itself
if we take a look at what we have here
we can tab between stuff we can shift
tab between stuff
but the up and down arrows don't work i
remember reading that over there that we
needed to make these up and down arrows
work um
let's let's how about we start there so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write a little on key down uh listener
let's put that maybe right here on the
header
so what does this do this listens for
arrow up this listens for arrow down
this listens for escape it's a personal
favorite um i like the idea of hitting
escape to quit an accordion uh and what
do we want to do when we have this let's
say on arrow up i wanna scroll up uh
arrow down scroll down escape close it
uh i think that's probably more
appropriate for a parent component uh so
let's let's just add some stub functions
here maybe something that we will uh
grab from the props so something like
this
okay i like that i like how that looks
okay let's let's move to the accordion
now so this is probably where we're
going to control uh a lot of a lot of
this functionality um
you know i have an idea of how we're
gonna do this and i like the idea of
using a
use effect in our child component let me
let me put some code on the screen and
then we can talk through how it works so
the idea here is let's create a little
state
maybe something like a focused index
and what i want to do is i want this
parent to listen for these key up and
key down events it kind of knows what
index of the child is sending those
events
and all we really need to do is send it
to the the
item above or item below so we can
update this focus index and if we hop
here to the header again
we can actually maybe put in a little
ref here so i'm gonna put
a little ref here uh how about here
okay
and this ref will actually point to this
item right here
and what this ref i put in does is it
checks hey
should i be focused you know did did
something in the parent component tell
me that i should be focused now
and if if that changes uh and it's true
then focus me really straightforward
really simple
uh you can of course do things that are
much more complicated uh but let's let's
start simple for now okay so let's uh um
let's uh move in and let's start
stubbing out some of these functions so
the first thing i'm gonna do is put some
little empty functions that we'll use
here
okay so what do we have here we're
passing our is focus which we were using
over here uh we're uh passing our focus
focus previous and handle escape
uh
let's start with focus next so i'm gonna
i think
it's pretty straightforward that we want
to
set the index to the next one but
there's also a situation where what if
you're on the last accordion element
what does that look like that looks like
something like this
and you hit the down arrow
i i say we should loop up i believe i
saw that in the w3c that's very
comfortable uh navigation for me uh so
let's add that here
so what did we do here we said that uh
if we're on the last element we're gonna
loop to the beginning otherwise we're
just gonna go to index plus one
and because we uh are listening uh um
for changes in the focus index in the
child uh
this uh
this seems like it should work let's try
this together
hey there we go down arrow oh and it
loops okay i really like that
so the uh up arrow is uh pretty similar
so i'll just put in the code for that
real quick
boom
and you know let's test it together uh
let's go here down arrow works up arrow
works that's great uh and then escape
what do we want to do um i this is a
personal uh preference i like the idea
of collapsing according with escape so
let's try this i'm going to put in some
code here
i'm going to click on this
and i'm going to
[Music]
hit escape
so let's let's open this one and hit
escape hey that works
so one this is
very
inclusive right there there there are
individuals who wouldn't have been able
to comfortably use our uh accordion
before that now can there are people who
we are empowering but i genuinely
believe that this helps everybody
everybody has a better experience
because of this it just feels like uh it
feels intuitive it feels right um it
feels fun to use it's a simple accordion
component i know but uh it just it feels
fun
so that was your demo obviously there
are
libraries out there that you can just
how download it is to make your
components more accessible so what are
the ingredients
it's
being thoughtful about the markup by
using semantic html
it's incorporating aria attributes it's
making sure that keyboard navigation is
supported which can actually come from
the symantec markup and it's also being
clear about focus management
there's a lot of great resources out
there but two that we particularly
recommend are the w3c
examples page
and this website which has a lot of
information about different patterns the
first one is the one that we showed
during our demo which has
really detailed information about the
kinds of attributes you should be using
different considerations kind of at the
element level and then the second link
kind of takes a more philosophical
approach when it comes to different
components so why we can make different
choices and what the implications are
for those choices so we really encourage
you to check those out
so before we close out here uh i
actually had a question for you sophia
it's
been a year
and uh
i wanted to know uh
something not related to
computer science something a little
personal
what gives you hope
that's a really good question yeah this
has been quite a year
i think it's two things one thing is
just how resilient people have been
both at the team level and also what
the level beyond that people have found
really amazing ways to cope with
everything that's going on in the world
for my team at course hero we did a
virtual cocktail class
i think i heard that your team did a
virtual escape room which is really
really cool
um and then secondly i think what gives
me hope is how we've been able to
recognize the humanity in each other
um definitely of course hero but also
across all the different social circles
we're in
um i think being empathetic being
patient
and demonstrating our respect for each
other has kind of underlined the fact
that beyond
us being devs
you know we are humans we have basic
needs and we should take care of each
other in different times
what about uconn
um you know it's uh like i said it's
been a year um i think sometimes it just
feels
like the world might be falling apart
and sometimes it feels like there's a
lot out there to be scared of and
sometimes it even feels like that
feeling might never go away
um but interestingly
tech
represents hope to me
tech to me is a promise that the future
will get better you know
i learned the word doom scrolling this
year if you look it up it's just this
idea that you keep going on twitter and
keep finding more and more scary things
there's always going to be something
scary something negative out there but
no matter what it seems that phones
always get a little thinner computers
always get a little faster and every
once in a while something new comes out
that just feels magical
in those moments
that magic can inspire a sense of wonder
and for me hope you know i i became an
engineer because it allows me to shape
what this slightly better future will
look like and i think that we focus on
accessibility because it allows us to
make this slightly better future more
inclusive as
well this was an awesome talk sophia
thank you so much for setting this up
thank you for uh having me as a part of
this
oh thank you thank you for everything
you've shared everything you said really
resonated with me as well and
to the people watching this talk i hope
it brought you something both in terms
of learning about accessibility but also
thinking about who we are as people
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back
welcome back anjana i'm happy to see you
today
on this wednesday we were just talking
before it's hard to believe that it's
only wednesday there's been so much
that's happened in three days during
this conference
and i i'm excited to get into this third
day i mean it's it's only day three it's
amazing um we've had so many great talks
uh
already and topic tables and
such great sponsors but uh i'm just
excited to get kicked off today my name
is jonathan catrell
i am a director of technology at pbs i
also host
developer t which is a podcast for
engineers like yourself who are looking
to level up in uh in their careers
and
i'm excited to get going today anjana uh
once you introduce yourself nick
yeah we are really excited to be back
with you for day three um in case you
haven't been able to join us the last
couple of days hi i'm anjana vakil i'm a
software developer and developer
advocate at observable
and i am really excited that we have one
more action-packed day of amazing stuff
for y'all
and we are super excited to tell you all
a little bit about what's going to
happen today and also jump right into
our talks but first i want to make sure
we give a huge thank you and shout out
to our amazing sponsors who've been
making this all possible so thank you so
much and please everyone join us in
thanking flexport course hero imagex
versailles off zero hassara vonage
netlify and mux
awesome sponsors sponsors make the world
go round for uh events like this so it's
it's wonderful
to have such great sponsors this year we
hope that you had a chance to hang out
uh with those sponsors this morning in
the past two days because they have some
of the best engineers working at those
companies
official expo sessions are now complete
but many sponsors will still be hanging
out at their booths make sure you go and
say hi you can find that in hop in which
we're going to continue talking about
because it's such a an interesting
platform with so much more going on than
just the main stage so make sure you
click around and explore a little bit
definitely and also a huge thank you to
uh free code camp who is making our live
stream possible we have folks joining us
on hop in live but we also have folks
tuning in to our youtube live stream so
huge thank you to free code cam for
making that happen and whether you're
looking on the stage on hop in or
whether you're watching the live stream
you're gonna see some amazing talks
today so get pumped get ready because we
have some awesome talks coming your way
from becca bailey brian larue lee
robinson cassidy williams and then we're
going to
cap off the day and the whole conference
with a very special live episode of
syntax fm with west boss and scott
telinski
exciting
wes and uh and scott are much more
entertaining and funny then i can be in
a live setting so i'm excited for that
one uh and as the previous two days have
as it's been true in the previous two
days the morning and the afternoon talks
will be broken up by live topic tables
with speakers and other experts so make
sure you check out those topic tables
you can find them let me see if i get it
right this time over there the sessions
are over there in hoppin uh you click on
the sessions you can go and join a topic
table those have been really fun and by
the way when you're in a topic table you
can actually show yours show your face
it can be kind of like those the big you
know brady bunch style zoom videos
or zoom meetings rather where you can
show your face and share your voice as
well and ask questions in that way
as long as that particular topic table
is open to that
yes definitely and please um remember
that in all of our interactions with
each other whether in the topics table
sections in the uh in this the chat um
or even in the youtube comments all of
our conversations with each other we
want to keep this a very safe and
respectful place so please everyone
please keep being considerate keep being
respectful keep taking responsibility
for your actions um and remember that we
are all abiding by the code of conduct
which you can find at reactathon.com
conduct
if you ever do feel unsafe or harassed
or someone is just trolling you
unnecessarily
you can report them by clicking on their
profile and clicking report user even if
it's questionable if you're thinking
maybe i should maybe i shouldn't please
do that
because we'd rather have the report than
you feel
like you were
like you were hurt or harassed this will
send a report to the organizers and they
will pay attention to it and they will
handle it
absolutely all right well
without further ado
let's jump into these amazing talks what
do you say jonathan who we got up first
yes i'm excited yeah first is becca
bailey becca is a front-end engineer at
formidable with a deep love of react
typescript and graphql
after previous career as an elementary
music and fine arts teacher she loves
helping artists and career changers
understand software
i love this i love how many folks we
have speaking at the conference and
attending the conference and being
present at the conference who have
transitioned uh into this wide wonderful
world of tech and react from other
industries other jobs um love this so uh
today becca is gonna tell us a little
bit about how to love refactoring our
code which i am really excited to hear
about because refactoring is always a
huge headache to me so i'm excited to
change my mindset about it and so we're
going to learn how we can love
refactoring without avoiding or while
avoiding unintentional changes to our
existing logic and we're going to learn
how refactoring can help us simplify
create a foundation for future work and
better communicate our intentions for
our code base which i love that was one
of our kind of subtle themes yesterday
was how our code really communicates
with our teammates so we're delighted to
have formidable engineer becca bailey
show us how to find joy in refactoring
uh by marie condoing uh up to levels of
organization and cleanliness that marie
kondo would absolutely approve so please
everyone join us in welcoming becca
bailey
hi i'm becca
i'm a software engineer and engineering
manager at formidable
and today i'm going to be talking about
refactoring and sharing some strategies
for how we can hopefully make
refactoring
one less stressful thing that we have to
deal with this year
for those of you who are not closely
following american or japanese popular
culture
marie kondo is the author of the
life-changing magic of tidying up
as well as the star of the life-changing
manga of tidying up
and a netflix series
a couple years ago i decided to read her
book and i attempted to put her
principles into practice
in my messy 600 square foot chicago
apartment
i really expected to hate this entire
experience
but actually i didn't
in addition to learning some new folding
skills
i learned about how reducing the number
of things that i own
helps me to better appreciate the things
that i have
and when we know and appreciate the
things that we have
it turns out that we're less likely to
leave them lying around on the floor
so this got me thinking about how to
connect these these practices to the
code that i write
because there are many days when none of
my code brings me joy
but unfortunately just throwing it away
is not a viable option
so this brought me back to the concept
of refactoring
what is refactoring
well according to the book refactoring
by martin fowler
code refactoring is the process of
restructuring existing computer code
changing the factoring
without changing its external behavior
so there's a word in there that we might
not be familiar with which is factoring
and factoring refers to the internal
parts of a program
or the implementation details
so let's note that if we're making
breaking changes to the public-facing
api of a library
or even a top-level component
while this is often necessary it's not
actually by definition refactoring
refactoring means changing the inside
without changing the outside
this brings me to my personal definition
of refactoring
to me refactoring is an opportunity to
change your mind and ask yourself
what decisions would i make differently
if i could write this code again
sometimes when we talk about refactoring
we're referring to the process of
modernizing our syntax
in react this might involve refactoring
from
a class to a function component
replacing deprecated life cycle methods
or converting state and life cycle
methods to hooks
this is often a great and necessary
thing to do but i think this is a
separate concern
from refactoring for code style and
readability
modernizing your syntax is a part of
refactoring
but at least for me it's not the entire
reason that i refactor
you might discover that using hooks
context suspense or other modern react
apis
might aid you in your pursuit of human
readable code
but in my view modern syntax is a tool
and not an end goal when refactoring
refactoring isn't just about code
quality either
in my experience
the pursuit of artfully crafted software
can lead to a lot of pride about your
work
but unless you're deliberate about
respecting deadlines
embracing alternate viewpoints and
collaborating with your team
it sometimes just makes software
engineering more exclusionary to people
who don't subscribe to a specific set of
engineering principles
one of the things i really loved about
marie kondo's philosophy is that it's
not just about buying stuff from the
container store
and redecorating your house to make it
look like a beautiful minimalist
magazine cover
likewise
the end goal of refactoring isn't to
have perfect or beautiful code for its
own sake
so when do i refactor
when i organized my apartment a couple
years ago my goal was to feel less
stressed every time i came home from
work
after dealing with this anxiety for a
few months i knew it was time to
reorganize
likewise there are some things that tell
me it's time to refactor my react code
my general rules are to refactor when
your code is hard to test
hard to
understand or hard to change
for example if you find yourself mocking
out a lot of external libraries
or walking on eggshells around your code
base or just scratching your head a lot
when you try to read your own code
it might be time to refactor
but more specifically
here are some things that i see in react
projects
that clue me in that i might need to
change some things
these things include out of control
props
so usually if i have 27 props on one
component that tells me that there's
something wrong
nested conditionals
so conditionals that are really hard to
follow
confusing variable names
or components that are doing too many
things that are uncertain about what
their responsibilities actually are
these are some general best practices as
i know them
but i'll tell you this
if you do your job for a while if you do
regular code reviews and collaborate
with your team
and practice refactoring
i promise you you will develop your own
sense for knowing what to refactor
a couple more things to note before we
move on
first of all
it's really common to think about
refactoring as a negative thing
as something that only happens when we
write bad code
i call this get blame refactoring
however
refactoring doesn't mean that you or
someone else did something wrong
maybe you made the best choice you could
with the knowledge you had in the moment
but now you have more information or
more expertise and you've changed your
mind
it's okay to change your mind
there's no shame in refactoring
or having someone else refactor your
code
so as we're talking about how to
refactor
let's talk about discarding
a key tenet of marie kondo's philosophy
is to start with discarding
while i know most of us have some amount
of legacy code to maintain and we don't
have the ability to just throw out
everything that doesn't bring us joy
it's also not unusual for us to hold on
to code that we don't need anymore
maybe it's a class that your co-worker
wrote
a year ago that you don't quite know
what to do with
or some utility functions that are no
longer useful
or some old comments that don't apply
anymore
perhaps we're afraid to get rid of code
because we didn't write it
we don't understand it
or we're uncertain about whether we're
going to need it someday
but you can discard it
worst case scenario
we can use three magic words to bring it
all back again
this is one of my favorite things about
programming because no matter how messy
it gets no matter how much we mess up
it's really easy to reset everything and
try again
so i don't know about you
but the practice of refactoring isn't
always a joyful experience
making changes to the structure of our
components can result in confusing
errors
test failures and unintentional changes
to the to the behavior of our components
have you ever introduced a bug by
refactoring
i know i have
so
this is why i love
writing tests
testing sounds stressful
especially if you're not used to doing
it
but
believe me when i tell you that this is
the number one thing you can do to
transform your refactoring work
from a chore
to an actual relaxing experience
however
not all tests are made alike
so here's an example of a way that tests
can
not help us refactor
let's say i have a simple class
components
i'll call this a drawer since marie
condo loves putting things in drawers
i have some states
and a render function with some
conditional logic
now if you don't understand what's going
on here don't worry because neither do i
and that's why i'm refactoring this
component
so using a tool like storybook i can
test that this component works
and
let's say that this component has some
existing tests
this syntax is a little less common now
but if your code has been around for a
few years there's a good chance that i'm
using a test renderer like enzyme to
test my code
enzyme allows me to access the props and
state of my component in order to make
test assertions against them
i can run my tests and everything works
great so far
so now i'm going to start refactoring
okay i know i said that we shouldn't
refactor just to modernize syntax
but
hooks are cool so i'll start by
switching this class component out for a
function with a used state hook
and look at that it got shorter already
but
hold on now
when i run my tests again
something is broken even though i know
the component works the same way it did
before
so
let's read that error message
it says
shallow wrapper states can only be
called on class components
well
at least it's a pretty helpful message
because it tells me that i'm not able to
access the state
of my component anymore because it's no
longer a class
well it works the same way
but this tells me something about my
tests
the things i was testing
were actually the implementation details
if i can break my tests by changing the
name of my state variable
or changing the internal function name
or removing my state altogether
this makes refactoring difficult
the thing that i care about when
refactoring is actually the way that
this component behaves
so if i look back at this component from
the perspective of a user
i can see that when i click the open
button the contents are visible
and when i click the close button the
contents are hidden again
so let's write a test that says this
instead
while i can still use enzyme to do this
i'm as long as i'm changing my tests i'm
actually going to switch my tests to use
react testing library
which is a test renderer built for these
kinds of behavior integration tests
well
this time i'm not using any internal
component apis
but i'm able to say what the user should
be able to do
so now i'm rendering my components
i'm clicking the button with the text
that says open
and now i'm expecting my
component to have some inner html
that is the that is the props or that's
the children
i no longer care about
my inner props or states
so this test passes for both versions of
my components
once i add a couple more tests i should
be start good to start making more
changes to this component
without so much fear of breaking things
so here's the part that makes
refactoring really satisfying for me
which is having the ability to make
small incremental changes
while relying on my tests as the source
of truth
now i can gradually untangle these
nested conditionals
i'll start by adding one overarching
conditional
and then step by step i'll remove the
ternary statements that are making
things more confusing
if i were actually refactoring this i
would be using a test watcher to check
after each step to ensure that my
functionality hasn't changed
and the final result might tell you a
little bit about the code that i
appreciate
notice how i haven't made this function
any shorter
is actually got a few more lines of code
and a little bit more repetition
but
because there's one conditional
instead of three
it's actually easier for me to tell
what's going on
now this isn't strictly related to
refactoring but along the way you might
discover another pain points which is
file structure and code organization
and since i am talking about
marie kondo i should also talk a little
bit about putting things away
marie kondo would say that the goal of
reorganizing
isn't just to make it easier easy to
find your belongings
but also to put them away
for example
if this
the shoes you wear every day probably
shouldn't be stored in a bin under your
bed
because you're never gonna remember to
put them there
likewise the goal of file organization
isn't just to make it easier to find
things
but also to make it easier to know where
to put new code
there are lots of philosophies on this
but my basic rule of thumb
is to group things together that are
used together
and to avoid really deep nesting
because if we use lots of deep nesting
and a really complex file structure
it's going to be much harder for me or
the next person who comes along to know
where to put things in that complex
structure
if your imports are a mile long it might
be time to rethink your component
organization
and that will help your refactoring to
go a little bit more smoothly
so for me
i like to think of refactoring as a
daily practice
every time we refactor we have an
opportunity to leave something a little
better than we found it
now i haven't sent out an official
survey
but i'm willing to bet that the number
one reason why we don't refactor all our
code all the time
is because we don't have time
when there are looming deadlines and any
number of things going on in the world
right now
the struggle is real
so rather than refactoring all at once
the more we can make refactoring a part
of our daily routine at work
the easier it will be to find the time
and to get the buy-in from our team
i don't think it has to be a prioritized
item on your backlog by itself
it can just be something that you take
an extra few minutes to do while you're
working on a new feature
or even just when you have a few spare
minutes
when you are
when you're
to clean up something that you've
already done
now i don't want to get anybody in
trouble here
but i'm going to say that most of the
time
you probably don't even need to mention
it to your product manager that you're
doing it
but
speaking of product managers
how do i get other people on board
especially when we have bigger
refactoring work to do
because sometimes this is where it gets
really tricky
if we don't have a team that values
thoughtful code reviews and
collaboration
chances are
there will be someone organizing their
one little drawer for all the rest of
your house stays messy
or worse
you will all be organizing your drawers
and there will be a different system for
each one
and there will be no consistency
one of the best things you can do for
your team is to be consistent in code
quality and style
so the goals when refactoring are clear
this might mean making some compromises
with your team members about code style
and how you're writing it
sometimes in my experience it helps to
document the this style and testing
practices
that way even if there are older or more
inconsistent parts of the code base
we have a shared idea of what we're all
working towards as we're refactoring and
making incremental improvements
like the end goal of tidying up is to
better appreciate the things you own
the end goal of refactoring is to better
understand your own code
and build systems that other people can
also use and understand
now this might be a little out there for
you
but
i think marie kondo would say
that the key to refactoring well
is gratitude
for the work that has already been done
both by you and by other people who have
worked on your code base
gratitude is the antidote to the
scarcity mindset that tells us we need
to stockpile 23 pairs of jeans just in
case the apocalypse happens and we can
never go to the gap again which
admittedly sounded a lot crazier
when i was writing this talk nine months
ago
but anyway
we can have gratitude even for the
things that we're getting rid of even
for the code that doesn't work anymore
or that doesn't fit our current
standards
marie kondo says you'll be surprised at
how many of the things you possess have
already fulfilled their role
by acknowledging their contribution and
letting them go with gratitude
you will be able to truly put the things
you own
and your life in order
when i re approach my refactoring
process with gratitude
i can acknowledge that i learned
something from this code
even if the thing i learned
is that i don't want to write code like
that anymore
now go forth and write code that sparks
joy
thank you very much
amazing
love it when talk spark joy amazing talk
from becca please everyone let's give a
warm virtual round of applause for becca
bailey and this awesome talk about khan
mar in your code konmariing your code
and yeah we have the extra special treat
of having becca live in our virtual
studio with us today um so we get to
chat with her right now so everyone
please join us in welcoming becca to the
stage
hi
welcome we're so pleased to have you
here
thank you so much for the amazing talk
um we are just i'm i'm i love this topic
i love this idea that uh you know you
can kind of find more joy in your code
base by approaching the code that you no
longer need as um not a burden but
something a nice you know something to
approach with gratitude as you said in
the end um so i just i'm so curious how
did you come to choose this topic to
talk about today what made you choose of
all the many things that you could talk
about at react-a-thon uh what made you
choose this one
yeah so back
i guess it was like a year and a half
ago when i was actually writing this
talk um because of all the things that
have happened this year
i was in a job where i was just
refactoring a lot um it was a code base
that had been written very quickly
and in order for me to make changes to
it it just involved a lot of reworking
of the code that was already there and
it was not always a very pleasant
experience it was really hard sometimes
because as the new person on the team
and
just in a messy code base it was really
like there was a lot of pressure not to
break things and
not to make it worse than it was to
begin with so i learned pretty quickly
how to use testing retroactively in
order to refactor well and that was
hugely helpful for me
and i just wanted to share that
awesome you mentioned that sometimes
it's scary to refactor or deprecate code
especially if you didn't write it
and especially if you're a newer
engineer on the team uh i can imagine
coming into a team and seeing code that
a very senior engineer someone who's
kind of moved on into even moved into a
management because maybe they're even
your boss right uh they wrote that code
and now it's your turn to delete it all
so um and that can be scary so i'm i'm
curious do you have advice for how folks
can build the confidence to refactor or
even throw out
all of that non-joyful code
yeah um and that can be really scary um
i think my advice is just to remember
that
just that if you're coming to code that
somebody else wrote that is hard for you
to understand or hard for you to test or
hard
hard to work with
you're probably not the only one who
feels that way there are probably a
bunch of other people on your team or
junior developers or new people who
would come on after you who would feel
the exact same way
so
just remember that it's not just you
and that it's okay to
to change things over time
and it even if somebody even if the
person who wrote it is like the best
engineer at your company i'm betting
that there are things that they would
look back on and be like oh man i can't
believe i wrote it that way
yeah i love that i love remembering that
you're you're not alone that like if
you're struggling with something you're
not the only one who's gonna struggle
with that that's just amazing advice in
general i think and i know for um you
know a lot of us and as we heard from
your bio um you also made the transition
into tech from a different field from
from being a teacher right very exciting
yeah and we had we i i as i mentioned
yesterday i get really excited
especially for uh to hear about folks
who are engineers who used to be
teachers because that's also my
background so um you know in the spirit
of remembering that there are folks out
there who are thinking about making that
transition maybe going through that
transition remembering that those
struggles again that you're not alone
that other folks have been through this
would you mind sharing with us a little
bit about
how you decided to make that change and
what that process was like for you
yeah absolutely um so
i
graduated from college with a degree in
music education i was really excited to
be a teacher um i was living in chicago
at the time so i was teaching in a lot
of like chicago public schools after
school programs
i spent a year teaching abroad in
guatemala which was really fun
but then after i after that experience i
was coming back to the united states
um
i
had like a bajillion different things on
my resume didn't couldn't really find
like a steady job that i could stick
with for a long time because of the
recession and just the challenges in
education right now
um
so during that time that i was living
abroad i was blogging a lot and i was
spending a bunch of time like fixing my
wordpress blog and it just became a huge
interest of mine
so
i discovered all these resources for
learning to code online um
found
meetup groups and like a support
community and then yeah basically i came
back to united states and decided to
make that transition and
went to dev boot camp
took a job as like that had an
apprenticeship program where i was
really able to work my way into like a
full-time engineering job
so
yeah i mean it's basically the story of
like i
had i was struggling to find a steady
find steady work and make money and
found something else that was a little
bit better for that
i'm so happy
yeah
go ahead end up here with us
sorry me too yeah i think your story is
is very um
is very much
going to resound with a lot of people a
lot of people probably have similar
echoes to what you've experienced so
thank you so much for sharing with us
today and for for giving us this
excellent talk uh where can folks follow
you
or your work where can they hear more
from you
yeah um well you can for all of my
contact info you can go to my website
which is becca dot is pretty easy to
remember and that should have my twitter
links my blog posts um
my blog has been kind of quiet for a
while thanks pandemic but hopefully
we'll have a few more things up there
after this conference for you to follow
and yeah i would be very happy to talk
to you more in the react-a-thon chat or
on twitter
you can find me online
awesome awesome well thank you thank you
so much
been such a pleasure
everyone please join us in thanking
becca for an amazing talk and thanks so
much for joining us for this chat
you're welcome have a great day
react-a-thon
all righty wow
i love that we can kick off the day with
all this uh joy and and positivity and
refactoring and tough subjects like that
and
talk about changing careers too i love
that this is sort of becoming a a subtle
uh sub-theme of the conference
yeah absolutely and i think we're gonna
keep on talking about hard things today
we've got an excellent talk coming up
here
in just a moment from lee robinson
lee is a developer a writer and a course
creator
he currently works at versailles a
solutions architect helping educate and
grow the next js community he frequently
speaks about front-end development
design and the future of the web
yeah and today um we are going to be
hearing from lee about data fetching
with nexjs um so this is a hybrid react
framework that empowers you to choose
your data fetching strategy on a
per-page basis which is pretty amazing
and so i think we're going to hear a lot
about client-side rendering server-side
rendering static site generation
incremental static regeneration when to
use all of those and what those mean
which i certainly need to learn
um yeah and so you know we'll see i
don't know maybe he'll tell us about the
next generation huh
but um
no just no
star trek fans about okay all right well
anyway uh if you're not familiar with
nexjs don't worry you're in good company
me neither so we're gonna learn about it
from leigh and we're gonna hear about
some of the main features of the
framework so without further ado please
join us in welcoming lee to the stage
hey everyone my name is lee robinson and
i'm a solutions architect at burcell and
today i'm going to be talking about
nextgs i'm going to give a little
introduction and then talk about the
different ways that you can do data
fetching inside the framework
if you haven't heard of nextgs that's
okay i'll give a quick introduction it's
the most popular and the easiest way to
build react applications and it includes
a lot of functionality that you would
need to probably use in your react
application anyway as an opinionated set
of defaults that are easily extensible
and easily customizable so routing is
included in the framework by using next
router
by creating a new file at pages slash
index.js or about.js you can use file
system based routing to easily create
the different routes in your application
it has image optimization built in using
the next image component
there's react fast refresh so it's very
easy to work with the framework locally
and see fast rebuilds and have a great
developer experience
to host files all you need to do is drop
them inside of a public folder there's
built-in support for css and sas and it
easily works with popular libraries like
tail and css
if you need to do serverless functions
or any sort of back-end functionality
you can actually merge the front-end
world and the back-end world using api
routes by just making a new file at
pages api
user.js or something similar there's
even support for internationalized
routing
typescript support and last but not
least a really important one is
code splitting and bundling so when i
visit the index right of my application
we're only serving up the javascript for
that route which means that our pages
are going to be more performant because
we're shipping less javascript to users
and it also
if there was an error on the about page
or the contact page that javascript
would be in a separate bundle which
helps improve the resiliency of your
application as well and that's all
configured out of the box so you don't
have to do anything so lots of great
defaults in the next js framework and
because of that we're seeing nextgs
growing very quickly so over the past
couple years it's became the most
popular framework for building react
applications and
excitingly we're seeing it being used
from the medium to large size businesses
all the way up into the enterprise so
lots of great logos on here that we love
to see using next.js and lots of happy
customers
and as i mentioned at the start of this
i work at versailles which is the
easiest way to deploy your react
applications
and our mantra is develop preview ship
so you start by developing your next.js
application taking these building blocks
of react components and providing a
great developer experience
then you push it to a get branch and you
get an automatic preview url where you
can view your changes
collaborate with stakeholders and
share across your company to developers
or designers or leadership then you just
simply merge your branch into production
and it's immediately available on
vercell's global edge network and it
takes care of all the hard things for
you like setting up domains and dns and
ssl encryption asset compression cache
invalidation all that stuff are
automatically handled by versailles edge
network with a nice user experience and
developer experience to go with it so
that's the company i represent and
they're also the creators of nextgs and
what i want to talk about today is
the different data fetching strategies
with nextgs because it's something that
i see people get tripped up with
a lot so we're going to start off with
the most basic next js application you
could start here with just mpx create
next app or by adding next
react and react on to your application
and then all it takes to build an xgs
application is one file so pages slash
index.js or about.js and when you export
a react component from your file that's
all it takes and this file will be
pre-rendered to html on the server
now
there's a variety of different data
fetching methods that you can do with
next.js you've probably heard of some of
these you have client-side rendering
server-side rendering static site
generation and you also have incremental
static regeneration which we'll get to
here very shortly so the the first
concept that i want to talk about is
pre-rendering so no pre-rendering is a
plain react.js application on that
initial load the app has not rendered
and you just see a white screen you
might have seen this before if you tried
to load a react application with a large
bundle with a very very slow internet
connection
then after that javascript loads and the
hydration period happens the react
components are initialized and that app
becomes interactive so that's no
pre-rendering
with next.js
you're using pre-rendering so on that
initial load the pre-rendered html is
displayed and it comes from the server
then as the javascript loads and your
application hydrates those components
become initialized and it becomes
interactive so for example like links
so the first data fetching strategy i
want to talk about is static generation
and this is where your html is in one
case generated at build time and then
reused for each request so for example
we build a production build of our
application with next build
then this html is generated and when a
request is made to your page or your
website
every single request is going to reuse
that statically generated html file
which is really easily hosted at the
edge by something like versel
now there's two different types of
static generation without data and with
data
so if we think about that about example
that i showed previously very simple
react component when you do a next build
and that html is generated since we
weren't doing any external data fetching
that page is going to be pre-rendered
using static generation without data
i would say this is somewhat common if
you have like an index page or other
marketing pages where you just have
static markup and you don't need to
fetch any external data but you probably
also want to do static generation with
some external data sources so for pages
that need to fetch that data when you
run next build
it will fetch that external external
data so for example information about
your products or information about
your blog posts and then the html will
be generated after that promise resolves
and you fetch that information
so for example i just got a quick code
snippet here the main thing to focus on
is get static props
when this function is exported
when this function is exported from your
react component from your page
you just have this function get static
props it takes in some context you can
make an api call to fetch something like
products and then when you return these
products as a prop it's forwarded to
your react component as you see we have
products available here now and now you
can iterate over those products and
display them out as a list for example
and the really cool thing about this too
is
with just one extra key you can actually
make this incrementally
regenerate now what i mean by that is if
you ran a full build of your application
at build time you would build all of
these files and you would ship them out
to something like for sale put them on
the server and when request comes in
they wouldn't be
recreated they would be static for the
life lifetime of your application until
you did a rebuild but with incremental
static regeneration
we can actually set a revalidation
period based on the cache control uh
header http request header so for
example if we say 60 seconds here
when a request comes in and it's within
those 60 second period it will just
reuse that same existing html that's
been statically generated
after that the next request that comes
in it tells our application hey you have
stale data now and the subsequent
request after that it will go and it
will update the cache with the new data
that's been fetched from the server so i
have a quick example here that shows
this very well using
github issues and leaving reactions so
in this example if you leave a
[Music]
you know a heart or a smiley face on
this issue and then you go back to the
demo you see it on the first request
it's stale
but then on the following request
that in the background that new version
of the page had been generated and then
you see the cache gets invalidated and
it gets updated with the new static
version and you didn't have to do
anything so the magic of nextgs handles
this completely for
you
now there's another thing to consider
with static generation which is when
your page paths depend on some external
data so git static props is one piece of
the puzzle
but what if i want to render out a bunch
of different posts and i need you know x
number of different urls for those posts
so when you build the app you have to go
fetch all the different posts you have
available and then generate a path for
each id of the blog posts in your blog
and we can do this using git static pass
which is another function that we can
export from our
file so for example here we have an api
that we're talking to post we're
fetching back some post
and then we're iterating over that to
tell next js all of the different ids
that are available for our application
so we return those paths and then we say
that we aren't we don't want a fallback
meaning that if one of those ids isn't
available it will 404. now if you want
to learn more about the other fallback
methods go check out the data fetching
documentation i don't have enough time
to get into all of them today but i at
least thought i'd mention them
the next thing i want to talk about is
server side rendering so on every
request we're generating new html so on
every visit that a user makes your
website it's talking to the server
there's a blocking request that's
fetching that html from your server and
you're probably doing this with data so
the request comes in you fetch your
products or your posts and then that
html is generated and sent to your users
so let's look at an example for this
we're using a function called get server
side props
now again this is just a function that
we export from our file we it runs in
the node.js context so we can talk to
things on the server and it's not
included in our client side bundle so we
can fetch some products again return
those as props to our react component
and it works exactly the same it's just
on every request
and the last one that i want to talk
about is static generation without data
and then you fetch on the client side so
bear with me now
we talked about pre-rendering
in the very simple example where you
were just serving up something that was
static
if we take a look at this example on the
right which is the vercell dashboard
we're seeing this nice loading skeleton
and in this example we're doing the
static generation without data where
we're pre-rendering on the server and in
this case we're pre-rendering a loading
state
the difference here is that on the
client side when that javascript loads
so at request time then we're making a
request to fetch some external data and
then we populate the rest of the page
with that data so the projects and the
deployments and my user information
let's take a look at an example for that
we have a profile and this is using a
handy library that vercell has made
called swr that is a react hook library
for data fetching so if we focus in here
we see that we're rendering a loading
state we're pre-rendering that from the
server and then on the client side we
can use swr to talk to an api route or
an external api which could be a rest
api graphql whatever you want and then
it returns that data and shows the name
on the profile
the best part about this is that nexus
is a hybrid framework and what that
means is that you don't have to choose
any of the different data methods that i
just talked about you can do static
generation on your index page you can do
server-side rendering for something like
a facebook news feed where the content
is very dynamic and needs to be updated
on every request
and then finally you could do static
generation for a bunch of different
posts on your blog posts or different
products for your ecommerce site without
leaving the bounds of your framework so
nextgs works great for small projects
and it scales up to really large
projects always staying within the
bounds of that framework and being able
to do different types of data fetching
and that's all i have today thank you so
much enjoy the rest of the conference
and feel free to reach out to me on
twitter at lerob with three e's if you
have any questions thanks
all right
thumbs up to this talk
yes thank you so much lee for this
amazing talk everyone please join us in
thumbs upping and applauding
virtually in the chat
um and yeah it's just uh it's just so
great to to see all of these options
that we have um with next js so if you
want to keep learning about that we've
got
again the chat and lots of ways you can
connect with the speakers and i know a
lot of other folks um are also
interested in this so connect also with
other conference goers but for now we
have got more exciting uh content for
you before we round out our
talk session and get right into the
topic table so we have another great
talk coming up from brian larue who is
the co-founder and cto of begin.com
which is the fastest and easiest way to
set up ci cd get ops for serverless web
apps on aws and brian is also the
creator and maintainer of openjs
architect which is an open source
framework for generating and deploying
aws standard sam cloud formation and um
also has coined the term fast stack
so very exciting and bonus
um they have a very cool url of arc dot
codes so
pretty pretty good url game there yeah
yeah yeah
so today brian is going to be talking
about dino uh and i believe that there
is some
uh some confusion uh in the community
about how to pronounce it maybe it's
dino maybe we will learn in the talk
that's one of the things i'm looking for
in this talk is how do you pronounce
this but also what is it maybe you
haven't heard about dinner
it is a brand new javascript runtime
from the creator of node with many
compelling characteristics he's going to
be teaching us about how to put deno
into production
let's tune into this talk with brian
hi everybody my name is brian leroux i'm
the co-founder of arcdoc codes which is
a tool for deploying serverless
applications to aws
and begin.com which is a tool for cicd
to aws
and today i am here to talk to you about
putting deno into production
you might be asking yourself
what the hell is deno it's a good
question denno is a next generation
javascript runtime
from the creators of node.js which is
not controversial
at all
i think it's great in fact that we
finally got some competition for node on
the back end and bringing javascript to
more places so it's less baggage of the
past it's always a good thing more
competition is always a good thing
especially for a javascript program
so knowing with a little bit about what
detto is you're probably asking well why
the hell should i care and that two was
a good question
and denno is important to you because
it's got a lot of qualities that
do make it interesting compared to the
available options for
server side or back-end javascript
and that's we're going to get into in
the talk today so the first thing i'm
going to show you is a completely
ridiculous benchmark that's going to
make everybody angry so this is
showing
console.log in node and in deno
in both cases i'm evaluating the result
and i'm putting it through a system
timer
we can see
node's a little bit slower
now console.log is not a realistic
program this is a very synthetic
benchmark and i acknowledge that what
we're testing here is the cold start
the startup time of a trivial program
and so this is testing the cold start of
the runtime the
application one time on the application
so
the reason this is important to you
things are moving serverless things are
moving towards single purpose uh
distributed stateless little functions
and these stateless little functions
uh are started up out of
nothing they're cold and if you have a
slow cold start you have a slow program
won't scale quickly and might even fall
apart
um nodejs is probably one of the best
serverless runtimes today
and deno is proving to be about twice as
fast on cold start this is trivial stuff
and probably won't matter for most
applications but a large application
those milliseconds could add up and this
will keep things compelling and it's
going to keep these runtimes on us
they're going to keep getting faster
which is great for us as javascript
programmers
the next part
is often invoked for fuddy reasons
not security and i think this is
actually genuinely a really good thing
to be thinking about today right now a
node can do whatever node can do on your
program and your program can do it to
your system so when you install a node
program
um it's kind of got carte watch
with deno we have to tell it explicitly
what features we're going to give it
access to and it splits those features
up by disk
network and
a whole bunch of other stuff
in this example at the bottom of the
screen you can see i've got
a tiny little demo program
you'll also notice there's no
dependencies which is pretty great all
this stuff is built in
and we're just going to encode a text
file it says hello world
and kind of underneath the header here
i've got demo run index ts
and it falls apart permission denied
we did not have the ability to write to
disk and so it wouldn't run that program
so i had to run it again with the flag
allow write or or you can allow all by
just doing capital a
and wrote our program
or wrote our text file run our program
and order text file
so that's cool uh that is a feature that
i think will be increasingly important
to folks that are security conscious
and it's just a nice thing to have
now the big daddy here
denno supports typescript out of the box
everyone's loving typescript these days
and a good reason and the reason this is
important to you
right now
it's not only the first typescript but
it includes
jsx and dsx files which is dope
so we can write our programs with react
and they're going to run without a build
step which is quite nice
the build stuff is that bad but it's
great to have this just built in
also great to have built-in are web
standards this one makes me particularly
excited
deno is sometimes described as a web
browser for your terminal which i really
like a lot
um
first thing you'll notice we've got es
modules built in
out the gate we've got wasm built in up
the gate got fetch built in out the gate
and a whole bunch of other browser
globals are built in like
alert confirm and prompt and this means
more of your code's going to be portable
without transpiling steps and so that
means your code will be both portable
and debuggable which is really nice
dental comes with a bunch of built-ins
also that are normally user land
concerns so
in the node ecosystem
the idea is uh
that the core is very small and that we
abdicate a lot of the normal
functionality and tooling to user land
to compete over
and this has been great for innovation
there's been tons of change and tons of
competitive products it's been kind of
terrible for putting stuff together
there's no vertical integration and a
lot of this stuff is commodity and you
shouldn't be arguing with your team over
lender rules or testing or bundling or
formatting this is all
stuff that should just be handled for
you and so deno does handle all this for
you
it has a built-in linker a built-in
tester built-in formatter and built-in
bundling
it's also got a really comprehensive
standard library in fact i'm going to
jump out
and uh pop up a web browser
just go to safari
wild man i'm gonna go to dinner.land
i do recommend you check out denno.com
and uh
we'll check out
the manual
one-time api standard library and
third-party modules
so this is pretty cool so demo comes
with like a nice manual that walks you
through the various features so
check that out it's like a book
and
because it's it itself uses typescript
fairly extensively it's got amazing docs
right out of the box
you know we know uh what everything
requires
great documentation about how to use
these things and it's
almost like a mashup of the go standard
library or runtime library and the
browser runtime library
which is
it's neat all this stuff is just built
in normally you'd be in npm installing
tons of programs just to do simple stuff
and in demo this is all just there for
you
and if it's not in the runtime there's
also a standard library which is hosted
by them
these are
frankly quite kind of a greatest hits
album of of the mpm registry just
anything you can think of that you
needed or wanted out of npm is going to
be
in this standard library
version by default and handled by
by the demo project which is pretty
great
so you're not arguing to team over which
uid library or which hashing functions
or whatever
too much in here to go through but one
other one worth noting they are building
a node.js compatibility layer
they still have a ton of work to do on
it but if you're
looking for an open source project to
get some commits into this is this might
be a really great one to try out
and then for finally just like with npm
there is a registry and there are
um user land modules but still
you know there's 1300 modules
so this is a great time to get in at the
ground floor
there's i don't know how many modules in
npm but there's a lot more than a
thousand
and
because so much is built in you might
not need all this stuff
um but it's it's worth checking out
yeah so really comprehensive things are
just built in just which is really great
um so we're gonna run a little demo
program in production and uh
and then we'll pop back and see how that
way
let's go take a look at an application
uh that i built for sign-in with slack
and so this is just a common oauth user
flow
or
click the assignment slack button takes
us to slack
slack's
eventually going to load
this oauth page
it's
asking for some information about me i'm
going to hit oh wow that's going to send
a request back to my local server
with a code
which deno is going to use to exchange
for a oauth token which it gets
my slack info
and now i'm signed in
and if we
reload the page i'm still signed in
and i can sign back up
pretty cool so let's take a look at the
code that made all that happen
just in my deno
ssr application folder
and we'll start at the very very sort of
top here
we've got a package.json and a deno
project and the reason i'm doing that is
we're using architect to deploy it
architect so this is a dependency
uh we have a npm script here for
starting a local developer sandbox
we're
letting architect know that we're using
the demo runtime
and then we want to have three lambda
functions
and the first lambda function is going
to be for logging in
it's going to point at this folder back
and log in
second lambda function is going to be
for logging out it's going to point to
backend logout
and then the last line of the function
will just intercept any traffic at all
and we'll pump that into the front end
as it should be
this app has a dot emv file
for
environment variables for the oauth
handlers so we've got a slack client id
slack client secret and slack redirect
you can get these by going to
api.slack.com signing up and
creating an application get your keys
we'll start the front end of this app
and just have a
look at that
so
index.ts is the entry file to our our
frontend
um
lambda handler
and it's named handler and everything
so this is a typescript file
and
we're going to respond with headers
that we're going to be generating html
we're going to give it a http status
code of 200.
i'm going to do the render and this is a
jsx file which is pretty cool so
uh
here we're pulling in the es builds of
react
and react dom server
and
we're using a library for encoding a jwt
token
and then we pull in our app itself
from our components folder so if we look
at the actual render function here we're
going to get the session
we're going to grab the client id and
the redirect environment variables
if the session looks good we're just
going to use that for props
and if the session doesn't look good
we're gonna get the client id and the
redirect and we'll pass that as props to
our app
and we're just gonna render that app to
strain
and uh
clubs are uncle
getting the sessions a little bit hairy
we're going to parse out the cookies
from the request
and when we find the cookie my session
we're going to
encode
the value of that cookie as a jwt
token or rather we're going to verify
that it's a jwt token we're going to get
the value of it
so
let's go take a look at the app
um
you'll notice here that we're using deno
types to pull in the react
type defs i just copied
those in
make it easier
to use
tsx or jsx the tsx is actually
optional you can just do jsx as you can
see so you don't have to do the
typescript thing if you don't want to
um
but i think sometimes you'll want to
anyways uh the app gets props and if you
know this could have been a boolean is
logged in but
we're just looking for an avatar if the
avatar is there we'll show the protected
route
and if it's not we'll show the
unprotected one
and this component is
about as silly and easy as you can see
like just hard-coded
href to log out
nothing really very special about the
slack button
all this is is a
an href to the slack api
oauth endpoint
so that's it um
that's the front end
uh
30 lines of code
so we'll take a look at the back end
next you'll notice there's no compile
step here either this is just
pure
pure code so
logging out's pretty easy
in deno land uh with api gateway being
our
our web server
we just have to pass it a cookie
and
we're going to expire that cookie this
is how you do that in dental land with
the standard library we we have a
response
pass that response
to
delete cookie function
that's a my session key
and that'll
get us the set cookie header that we
need to expire the cookie session
okay login is a little more involved and
this is where i think typescript starts
to shine we can see we opted into typing
our request handler here
the reason this is important is this is
a really nice map to future programmer
looking at this page wondering well i
wonder what they're doing like what are
they using this is a pretty nice hint to
say hey i'm
probably relying on cookies and i'm
probably relying on queer string
parameters
and here's our the interface that we
designed for our account payload
we're pulling payload out of the jwt
library we used
and uh we're extending that just to say
that our jwt is gonna have a name email
and avatar which i really like
see it's doing a little bit of console
log debugging
but go here and we grab our code if you
have an oauth request it always comes
with the code which you use to verify
and if we don't have one we're just
going to go back home
and say that we didn't find the code
if we did get the code we're going to
trade that for an access token this is
part of the oauth flow
and then we use that access token to
call the slack api to get the account
data
and
this is quite nice it's all typed and
then we'll take that account data and
we'll encode it as a cookie
which will set cookie on headers and the
response
just like you do with any old web
standard server
and
and that should be good we'll be logged
in so we take a quick look at get access
token and get account these are
both making api
both making api calls into the slack api
and this is where the web standard side
of things really starts to shine i mean
we're using fetch api
directly
really clean
just give it the slack api url with the
right data and
we can get back our access token
getting the account info is even cleaner
just call in the slack api the token
that we got
and then we're going to encode the
response into this
payload with name email and avatar to
match our account
data shape
now the payload shape
and then our set cookie
string
is basically the inverse what we were
doing before we're going to create a jwt
token
we're going to create a cookie
we're going to use the built-in standard
library set cookie and we're just going
to return that header
to write to the api gateway response
so
oauth
uh zero dependencies
maybe 200 lines of code
tops with deno which is pretty nice
so that is
building a little mini oauth app with
deno
and that's kind of the same old new
thing
we've got a javascript runtime with a
slightly better cold start
more interesting runtime security model
and a lot of things just built in that
you probably already used today we've
got typescript out of the box we've got
web standards out of the box and we've
got a comprehensive cli runtime standard
library
all built in and out of the box which is
great
i
want to thank you for joining me you can
find all the source code on my github uh
it's brian leroux arc example deno ssr
slack oauth that's a mouthful
and if you get a chance please check out
begin.com
and if you want to deploy this to your
own aws check out art doc codes and
stars on github
thanks
ah excellent talk uh about dinner as it
turns out that is how brian pronounces
it uh
and
you know if you haven't yet um if you
haven't yet
seen
another runtime
it's very possible that you imagine that
node.js is going to just take you
through your entire career right it's
possible to imagine that these things
only last
or these things will continue to last
forever but as we know our tools will
continue to evolve and so it's great to
see a talk like this because it reminds
us there's more to the story
than whatever it is that we used last
year right
so
i'm excited to welcome brian to the
stage with us uh today we're gonna have
a a discussion with brian about this
talk welcome to the stage brian
thanks for having me whoa i'm big now
this is great
hi
hi nice to meet you both uh that was a
lot of fun it's kind of neat seeing
yourself
come together with a lot of people from
afar and uh
yeah i'm excited to be here let's get in
let's get into it let's talk about this
deno thing rodino
i think so initially
let me let me throw i'll i'll tell
everyone what i know and what i know is
the maintainers or creators called it
denno
and then the community started to call
it dino because the little icon logo was
this little dinosaur guy
and uh now the
main creator ryan doll the dude who
created note also uh has started saying
dino i think just to confuse people so
you're you're fine to interpret this any
way you want
uh it's kind of like gif and jiff you
know pick the one that annoys you least
and uh someone will disagree with you
but
you know and and it brings up a a good
point that you know uh this is brand new
um so we're still
we're still establishing these norms
around uh community even understanding
what's going on um
you know like do we say
node.js or do we say no js
that was a topic in the early days so
i'm curious you know why should i even
care i'm coming to this as a you know
even a junior engineer and i'm just now
getting my feet wet with note what why
do i have to care about another runtime
what what's important about this
yeah i think the thing for me with deno
is that there's a lot of built-ins and
so the philosophy with node.js was
that there would be a very small core
that would start very fast and be very
portable for writing small networked
applications and the ecosystem would
fill in the gaps uh npm
and that's
uh have predictable results we now have
a huge ecosystem and we're sort of
living in the tyranny of choice there
isn't one way to do anything there's a
million ways and what's the best way it
depends on your
you know when the wind's blowing today
what's popular right now
and um
denno
uh defeats the law of triviality in that
it will take these decisions that you
normally have to make with your team
and make them for you it builds in
formatting it builds in lintina builds
in a standard library it builds in
a really comprehensive runtime library
and uh
because all this stuff is built in i
think it's got a good chance of having a
better developer experience which will
result in better uh velocity for the
teams that choose to adopt it now it is
early days
and you mention this when you're saying
like i thought you know maybe i could
you know ride this out with node for the
rest of my career and i actually think
that's possibly possible there's enough
javascript out there today that um you
know if you're a node developer you're
gonna you're gonna be able to find a job
for a long time to come there's a lot of
inertia for that existing code
but things do change in this industry
and we want more options especially on
the back end
a lot of other languages have multiple
runtime implementations and they're sort
of spoiled for choice
javascript doesn't really have that
we've got browsers
we've got desktop with things like
electron we've got mobile with things
like cordova and capacitor
but on the back end you know it's node
or
i guess if you're feeling masochistic
you could use the jvm but
that's about it so it's about time we've
had some more options and
i like that it's taking some really hard
line opinions and pushing those forward
in a new direction where we have a lot
of built-ins
and i don't think it's an either or for
what it's worth there's a lot of
zero-sum thinking in our industry
because it's largely venture-backed and
everyone thinks that there's going to be
one big outcome and there's going to be
a winner take all as it were and there's
no historical evidence that that's true
there's always been lots of programming
languages there's always been lots of
ids and there's always been more than
one way to do things and the right way
is what's right for you and your team
so well said yes love that and uh you
know it is really exciting to see to see
denno coming up and since it's so uh
early days as you said we know things
are moving really fast with denno and um
so i is anything exciting been going on
even even in the time since we recorded
this talk
totally uh yeah and this is you know
maybe the the downside of something
that's new is that it is moving fast
there's a lot to keep up with they've
been quite good on uh stability so there
hasn't been a lot of breaking changes
but they're still susceptible to that
especially since it's typescript based
which doesn't really have much of a
policy around breaking changes other
than to deny they happen while they do
it
but with the case of tenno anyways they
just did a big release 1.6 and the sort
of banner feature of dental one six is a
compile command
and we've wanted this for node for a
long time the idea is that you can take
an arbitrary program
compile that into a binary for all
operating systems with no dependencies
so you can take your your deno app and
you can turn it into an app app and uh
why that's important to you um one for
deployment this just makes life a lot
easier you're not waiting to download a
bunch of dependencies or setup steps and
two for distribution um for things like
libraries especially like uh tools
anytime you've run npm install dash g
you're installing someone's executable
node program
and that's you know a great distribution
channel and has been useful to a lot of
people but it's also a blocker if you're
a
java shop or python shop you might not
want node running on
your your developer's machines for
whatever reason or maybe you've blocked
installing globally so this will allow
people to create tools and redistribute
them as binaries and the binary it
creates is very small it's around 20
megabytes so
it's startup time is is ridiculous it's
like something like 10 to 20
milliseconds startup
so for cold starts for things like
serverless apps this is going to be
really important and i kind of feel that
this is
a major line in the sand
as a capability that node just does not
have
i think a lot of developer tools are
going to be evaluating to to do this in
future
super exciting
yeah
and so it's probably going to be
a really exciting year
yeah that is incredible to have that
flexibility to be able to to compile
uh down to that by you know it's
portable right so it's it's the the
dream that we always had uh in the back
of our minds with with java but now we
can write the the language that we
actually love so that's very exciting
what do you have planned at begin.com
for the for the new year
that's a great question um we've been
pretty busy in the last year uh i'd say
largely focusing on front-end use cases
begin has been mostly focused on
centering the idea of what does the
world look like when we build lambda
functions and we really nailed that side
but there was still a fair bit of
friction getting on board if you were
coming from a front end focused
context which a lot of people are
and serverless sort of first started
going i thought this was going to be a
revolution
from the back end but what i didn't
expect
is that technologies would democratize
back-end development and uh allow
front-end developers to play
uh with these tools and so a large part
of our adoption is coming from folks
that have hit a wall with
get requests and want to move beyond
that and do stuff with databases and
queues and
infrastructure as code so we have a ton
of features coming out this year to
help people that are building jam stack
static asset based websites and move
those into a dynamic world but
serverlessly
awesome awesome so exciting well so um
where can folks best follow you and your
work um and learn more about all these
exciting things to come in the new year
yeah my very easy to spell name
is brian leroux
it's
b-r-i-a-n-l-e-r-o-u-x and i am that uh
on all of the social medias so if you're
looking for me on github well you'll
find me at brian github
i'm always on twitter
not trying to stir anything up but often
in the middle of it
and uh
and uh yeah those are good places to get
in touch if you're just interested in
following along with the sort of begin
architect stuff you should follow those
twitter accounts um
begin and at arc serverless
awesome awesome well thank you so much
for being here with us today um and
yesterday we'll definitely have to
follow along yes we're so pleased that
you could join us thank you for the
amazing talk and for this great chat
everyone please join us in thanking
brian
so cool alrighty
so jonathan what a lot of great talks
we've had so far today
so good so good yeah and
all of it is very exciting i i love
refactoring and i love portability and i
mean it's it's just been a good day and
i'm excited to hear more um but i think
now is a different uh a different
section of the day right
yep i think it is time for us to move
into our topic table sessions
so uh just like the last couple of days
this is the time where we break away
from the stage talks to allow everybody
to get up close and personal with all
the speakers workshop instructors
sponsors and other subject matter
enthusiasts around different topics
so how can folks get uh jumped into the
topical sessions
all right i've got it down now they're
gonna go over there right go go go click
on sessions on the left side of hop in
and it's in the left menu you can browse
all the topic tables uh and there's a
lot of great topic tables that happened
yesterday and today there's going to be
even more uh there's so much to talk
about and you really these are very
flexible conversations and you are the
most involved in these topics tables
you can ask questions you can even show
your face as we mentioned before
if the topic table will allow for that
uh in in their particular discussion so
make sure that you go and check out a
topic table that looks good to you
definitely so you've got tons of options
you could talk about design systems with
the flexport engineering team you could
talk about dynamic apps with some
awesome engineers from netlify
engineering management is going to be on
the agenda with uh netflix engineer ryan
burgess and um we've got also topic
tables around nexjs which we heard um
about earlier so you can talk with
versailles engineer jj casper about that
and you can even chat with brian larue
who we just had speak about uh
serverless and deno and you can get all
your questions answered there so tons
of options too many to choose from good
luck with that
and talks are going to start back up in
a little over an hour so make sure you
keep an eye on the schedule
we will back be back here in just a
little over an hour so make once again
make sure you keep an eye on the clock
so you don't miss out on the next talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've had my heart broken into it
[Music]
but something's different next to you
[Music]
it's like my soul is set on fire
[Music]
feelings
[Applause]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the feelings
[Music]
feelings that i know
[Music]
for sure
i can't keep on this road alone
[Music]
and all this time i thought i knew
[Music]
i
[Music]
is
[Music]
the feelings that i know
[Music]
feelings
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
what have i been waiting for oh i can
run but i can't hide
the feelings that i know
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
expect
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is we're forgetting how to slow down
[Music]
so tell me
[Music]
never gonna let you down
[Music]
breaking up
[Music]
without your baby
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is something different
[Music]
[Applause]
so tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you give me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when you're with me and i realize what
it all means
[Music]
oh
[Music]
till the
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
till the sky
[Music]
falls down
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i was doing just
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
[Music]
i think you're perfect
[Music]
closer than anybody else
[Music]
for me
[Music]
fame
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
show me
[Music]
is
through the windows
[Music]
like superheroes
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like we wear our
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
forever
[Music]
don't
hold
back is
[Music]
come with us
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
don't hold back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've had my heart broken into it
[Music]
but something's different next to you
[Music]
it's like my soul is set on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
the feelings
[Music]
feelings
[Music]
take my hand the same for sure
i can't keep on this road
[Music]
alone and all this time i thought
[Music]
cause i can run
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
feelings
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the
is
[Applause]
what have i been waiting for oh i can
run but i can't hide
the feelings that i know
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
know next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whenever you cross my mind
we're forgetting how to slow down
[Music]
you give
i'm never gonna let you
[Music]
i got down baby
[Music]
don't you know your love is
without your baby
[Music]
nobody
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when you're with
what it all means
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
to believe
[Music]
is
[Music]
till the sky
[Music]
falls down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
for me
me
[Music]
so pick me up when you're done
[Music]
[Music]
i think you're perfect
[Music]
i was
[Music]
else
[Music]
for me
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i was watching you watch the sun come up
in this t-shirt
[Music]
show me
[Music]
is
[Music]
through the windows
[Music]
like a superheroes
[Music]
is
[Music]
how
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
don't
hold back tonight
[Music]
so come with us
[Music]
forever
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
don't hold back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i've had my heart broken into it
[Music]
but something stay different next to you
[Music]
it's like my soul is set on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
the feelings
[Music]
feelings that i know
[Music]
i can't keep on this road alone
and all this time i thought
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
[Music]
hi
welcome back everybody hope you had an
amazing time at our last topic table
session of the conference we've had so
many great topic tables over the last
few days so many great conversations
going on so really hope everybody
enjoyed that
and now
we get to kick off our last talk
of the day
and of the conference
and we could not be more excited to have
our final keynote talk be from the one
and only
cassidy williams
if you don't know cassidy better known
as cassadoo on
twitter and github and all the above
she is an amazing instructor and speaker
um she's a developer with netlify has
also worked for react training codepen
amazon venno and lots more really
impressive places and she's had the
honor of working with various
non-profits as well including seekis and
hacker fund as their director of
outreach
so cassidy is just such an inspiring
person in the developer community you
may have seen some of her amazing talks
at all kinds of super prominent uh
events and her amazing and hilarious
tick tocks and tweets um she is just
such an inspiration in the developer
community and she wants to inspire
generations of stem students to really
be the best that they can be
um and also very important to note she
loves mechanical keyboards and karaoke
woman after my own heart
so what are we gonna hear cassidy talk
about today jonathan
well we have to all
uh put our serious face on for cassidy
we if you've if you've ever heard of
cassidy you know that she's a incredibly
serious person uh and we've heard a
little bit of about next js today the
popular react framework today she's
going to give us a super serious
discussion about next js so please
welcome cassidy williams
[Music]
hello
and welcome to the most serious talk of
react-a-thon an incredibly serious
discussion about next js
i'm your incredibly serious speaker
cassidy williams you can find my very
serious handle cassadoo on twitter on
github
or just google it
you'll find some very serious results
now in this talk
i want to talk about serious business
because being serious is
serious business
if you use react chances are you've
heard of nexjs the react framework next
js is very very serious it has a lot of
serious business built in
with next.js you can use ssr and ssg
that's server-side rendering and static
site generation in a single application
the routing system is file system based
routing and so if you have a file in a
certain directory it's an automatic
route and this includes dynamic routes
as well
you can programmatically update the
site's head and a bunch of other
features per page and there's a lot of
built-in components for that as well it
has a very powerful api
plus there's some really cool developer
experience features like code splitting
absolute imports and css and js already
built in natively in next.js you don't
have to install any extra loaders on top
of that
serious developers use nexjs
but also nerds do too
and today we're going to be talking
about pranking people because yes you
can do all kinds of serious scaling cool
stuff with next js
and that's what most talks are going to
be about about next js so why not do
something fun for once and that's right
we're going to be pranking people with
next js so first i want to show you some
really basic things on how to set up
next js how a certain page works and how
a website might look but then beyond
that we're going to use some of these
features to build a fun little prank
website
okay so first of all
this is our next nutlify starter project
if you'd like to look it up you can find
it on github at github.com
cassadoo
nextnetlifestarter it's a very very
basic project and if you look at the
results you'll see it's just a welcome
to my app it's that's it so let's
actually look at the code a little bit
just so you can kind of get familiar
with it so first of all this is a very
simple thing where we have a header
component and then this description this
header component is inside the
components directory and it's truly just
a function that exports a header
component it's really not that thrilling
um and then inside the head this head
right here is actually a next api and so
when you have a next js site anything
you put in the head
will update in the title of the page and
so right now the tab over here says next
js starter but if i were to update it
saying next js demo and then save that
when the page refreshes you see next js
demo hey not too
not too crazy right all right
so if you look in the directories here
on the side
pages is really the only thing that you
need to get up and running with next.js
in pages that's where all your routes
are so in index.js index.js is the index
page the home page of your website in
app.js this is a global wrapper
and in app.js you don't really do much
it's really just something if you want
to install something globally throughout
your application which for example i
want to import styles globally across my
application and so i have this
globals.css
inside of here i just have some basic
centering and stuff if you see on the
application over here you can see it's
really just
centered
so that's what the global styles are and
that's what's imported in the app.js
which is automatically wrapping any
other page that you might have in this
application
and then this footer component i have a
footer.js which is a pretty simple thing
it's an html footer but one thing you
might notice is i have styles from a css
module css modules are automatically
built into next.js so if you want to use
them you can just use them you don't
have to add any loaders or anything so
this is a very very basic site if you'd
like to do a little bit more with it you
can by for example adding another page
and let's just say i want to say
fun
page.js now in this fun page i'm going
to copy all of this from index and put
it in here and then i'll just say
this is very fun
we'll call it fun page
like that see how fun that is wild okay
now if we go over to our browser and
then we go to slash fun page
look at that this is very fun
that is it that is how you make a page
that's how you make a route you don't
have to do any extra configuration to
just have these pages work now
page components in next.js are pretty
special because you can do some really
neat things with it when the site loads
and so both for static and for
server-side rendered pages there's some
really nice functions that you can use
and the one that i probably use the most
is one called get static props so you do
export async
function
get static
props
okay
now
the return value of this function is
passed to the page and so if you were to
call a bunch of apis and put the values
that you get from the apis the data you
get from the apis onto the page and you
statically export this website
then those api calls happen at builds
time not at run time and so you could
really save a lot of time when your
pages are being loaded on the screen for
your users because it's happening at
build time that part is really exciting
to me so
in this get static props you can do a
lot of different things i'm going to
call a very simple api
const
and we're going to get a response and
excuse me while i copy and paste from
the pokemon api okay we've got res and
then we're fetching so we're going to
fetch from the pokemon api we're going
to get charmander i'm going to do const
pokemon is equal to a weight and then
res.json
just like that
oh whoa that was some
sorry about that
okay cool
so now that we have these done we have
the data that we want what we can do is
we can return that to the page so i'm
going to return an object the object
will have props that are passed into the
page
and then inside of there i will pass in
pokemon just like that
and so now
inside of home we have props right here
and so i can get
pokemon from props and then anything
inside of pokemon i can pass to my app
right here and so for example instead of
having next js demo right here i could
do something like pokemon
dot name
so now it'll say charmander and it'll
say how about this hi charmander
and now i could say for example
[Music]
an image
i'll say
image src
equals
and then inside of here
pokemon
dot sprites
dot front underscore default if you'd
like to know this api go look at the
docs i've used it enough where i happen
to know how that works
oh and i forgot a little a weight down
here
and so if i save that
and then refresh the page look at that
we got high charmander and the title and
we got a little charmander in here and
so again this fetch call will happen at
builds time and won't happen at run time
i think that is super cool now i've
talked a little bit about routes talked
a little bit about this whole get static
props things we can also generate static
paths and so we can build what different
paths might be coming from an api route
or something at build time and
we can also have dynamic routes now if
you want to have a dynamic route what
you would do is you would create a new
file and you would say
anything
fish
dot js and you'll put it in brackets
like this
and that means anything that matches the
paths that would go to this fish.js is
what would actually be returned to the
user
i'm going to explain this to you with a
prank example
so this is a prank project that i built
i'm very proud of this prank project
people have fallen for the prank and
that's truly what matters so we have
this home component and in this home
component it is a very very basic thing
i actually used the same starter project
that i showed before and i have this
header let's prank people and then i
have a prank article right here
if you'd like to see it live you can
check it out in this let's prank people
thing right here and be like cassidy did
the
cassidy did
the best talk at
react-a-thon
and then if you click on it
[Music]
we get rick rolled
and so this is a fun little prank
project where it shows the title here it
shows the title up here and also i
programmatically updated the head so it
looks like a real article if you were to
share it on social media and so i'm just
going to show you that head component
really quick inside of this head
component
you can see we have the title here we
have the open graph title i made some
graphics for it it it looks like a real
article and so if you were to actually
paste a link to this on twitter or
something
you might just prank someone so this is
this is something that i had a lot of
fun with and now
with this i'm going to talk about a few
different things first of all
the dynamic routes we mentioned this a
little bit earlier
with these dynamic routes it's a very
similar thing as before where we have a
function and it's exporting a component
and it's in a
page component here because it is uh in
the pages directory now because it's in
the pages directory we have access to
certain functions and so the functions
that i used were that get static paths
which i mentioned a little bit and get
static props
now in get static props instead of
calling an api what i did was i got the
params of the url the parameters and in
get static pads i actually returned that
to get static props so in get static
pads this is something where i would say
hey i'm calling for example the pokemon
api again and i would have some variable
paths and then inside of there i would
have just all of the pokemon names
pokemon pokemon names in here and then
that paths variable would go right here
and so anytime i would go to
my app slash charmander my app slash
bulbasaur or whatever
it would show data from that but
if you have nothing there then it gets a
little interesting there's this thing
called fallback when you have fallback
is false that means any paths that are
not defined
inside of this array returns a 404
but if you have nothing defined in here
and then you put true
that tells next hey you can have other
routes that aren't defined inside of
here and so if you define notepads then
you can have some user-defined paths and
so if i were to for example have a prank
article and if you look at the url up
here i have this cassidy did the best
talk at react-a-thon thing that's
generated from that form
i can use that cassidy did the best talk
i reacted on i should have made
something shorter and pull it in to the
parameters here and get static props
then i'll do two title case and so i
take out all of the dashes in there add
spaces do uh do some title casing in
there and then i pass it as props and
those those props go to
article right here and then this is the
page component it's passed to the rest
of the page and so the prank head which
i showed you before all of the metadata
comes from that title and then we have
this you have been pranked this is
pulling from the current date and then
uh we have just the youtube video there
um and then we also have the title and
we add not at the end because that's the
best way to prank people i learned that
as a child anyway so we have that you
can look at the page and you can see
again you have the you have been pranked
you have the current date we have this
not after getting the title from there
and
that's about it we're just pulling
everything from the url
and so this is a really really
interesting concept where in next.js
typically this triggers something that's
called incremental static regeneration
now what that means overall is that when
you have a static website you have a
site that is built entirely it's built
once and then
you can go to all the pages that were
built but if you don't necessarily know
what routes a user might be going to you
will
go to some other routes that don't exist
and that haven't been built and
typically you can serve or side render
those or you can do the incremental
static regeneration thing now i'm going
to call it isr because that's long
with isr what it does is next js builds
that page at runtime and then later if a
user is to go to that page it will be
cached and that page will exist in the
future um or you can
server side render it either one works
but that's kind of how the whole
fallback thing works that's that's how
all of this works now i've deployed this
already and there's one really cool
thing that uh we haven't talked a lot
about at netlify but i'm really excited
about it and it is a next.js builds
plugin now if whenever you have a
website that you want to upload to
netlify you have what's called a
netlife.tamel or what you do is you run
a builds command you can have your
netlife functions in there your
redirects all kinds of stuff and we have
this brand new thing called netlify and
then plug-in next js what this does is
it allows you to do all of those things
that require runtime functions all those
things that require server-side
rendering with this plug-in using
netlife functions
and so uh what i really like about this
is i can kind of write my next apps
deploy them wherever i'd like with with
this plugin i don't have to worry about
making any code changes or anything to
make sure everything works seamlessly on
nutlify and so i installed this package
and
that's actually it if you if you look at
my package.json it's very simple we just
installed next react and react dom
we build it when we want to build it and
then netlify builds it and then during
that build it has the plug-in that runs
the entire thing and ships it and that
is the entire pranking application and i
think that it's so fun that this it's
kind of a simple application but you can
see how it could get more complex this
this functionality is so useful because
if you are
going the static site generation route
it's something that
often results in very large builds where
if you have thousands upon thousands of
pages you might have to wait a while for
your entire site to build granted your
users will get tons of benefits because
it's already built and loaded you can
just pull it from the cdn and it's done
but
your builds take a while with something
like this with these dynamic routes
being able to pull things from the
server you can have the best of both
worlds where some of your pages will be
static pages that are just loaded from
the cdn but the ones where you have just
a ton of blog posts for example or a ton
of product pages a ton of prank pages
something like this
you can just call a function you can
server side render it you can run it at
runtime and it'll just work and and you
don't have to wait for a build it might
take a little bit longer for the users
but honestly
i've experimented with this a lot
there's not that long of a wait it's
just a few milliseconds more and so this
is something that i i think is really
really powerful both for very serious
business but also for
very fun pranks
that being said i want to thank you so
much for your time today
i've been cassidy i hope that you uh
have a good time at the rest of the
conference if you have any questions i'm
gonna be around in the chat or you could
find me on the internet and talk about
very serious things but also please just
talk to me about fun things that would
be so much more fun and i'm happy to
answer any uh next questions any nutlife
questions and if you'd like to see this
project it is on github and then you can
also look at this url that i am putting
on the page post edit where you can
actually mess with the pranking
application thanks so much for your time
and have a good one
excellent talk a very serious talk
from
cassidy
we're so thankful that she is able to
maintain her composure with such a
serious topic as next js
uh so hopefully this has been such a
good conference uh jenna and i don't
know if uh if you want to talk about
some of the talks that we've had for a
minute um but i i've really enjoyed it
i know it's been an incredible few days
i mean action-packed like i don't know
if it's been a few days or a week or
like a month of content that we've all
just uh had
downloaded into our brains right here we
have heard about so many amazing things
we've heard about uh everything from the
uh
site generation and static
site site generation that we heard about
today with next um we've heard about
we've heard about um getting started in
uh tech
and in transferring careers changing uh
from different backgrounds we've talked
a lot about that we've had a lot of
great talks about uh things like
typescript and how type safety can help
save
some headaches uh from the developer
life that we all know and uh don't so
much love i mean we have just learned so
much
what else am i uh am i missing here
jonathan
well i i there's some this is such a big
ecosystem now it goes well beyond what
it was even just a year ago uh things
are kind of exploding in a very good way
um and and of course there's so much
more to come
not just today but in years to come uh
we we're very excited about the future
of react-a-thon but also
for what we have remaining for the rest
of the day um which we can talk about
here in just a minute
absolutely and yes um we have had so
many great folks uh come in and uh work
with us in different formats so not just
the socks we've also had these amazing
workshops these amazing topic table
sessions the sponsor booths so hopefully
everyone has had lots of amazing
opportunities to connect and that this
is not the end of anything this is going
to be hopefully the beginning of lots of
great conversations following out of
these amazing um spaces and forums for
us all to
get to know each other and dig into some
of these exciting topics and yes as
jonathan mentioned the conference is not
over we have wrapped up our stage talks
but we have a very special treat to
close out the day today we are going to
be hearing a live
recording of syntax live so uh syntax um
is a very exciting podcast syntax fm um
that we are going to get to uh be part
of all here together and it is hosted by
the incredible scott telinski and wes
boss so scott telinski is a web
developer and creator of
leveluptutorials.com
which features comprehensive tutorials
on everything from react to figma and he
is also importantly a father of two and
ask him about this one a breakdancer
super important super important uh yes
uh syntax.fm uh the the other person
that you've probably heard of uh on top
of scott is wes west boss is the creator
of many popular web development courses
including javascript 30.com probably a
lot of you that was your entry into
javascript in the very beginning
the
full stack advanced react and graphql
and his latest course master gatsby
these are all things that wes has been
creating you've probably learned
something from him and if you haven't
you probably will today and i know that
they have a lot of tasty treats for us
loaded up that's a syntax.fm cut there
nice so we are super excited to have
scott and wes um co-hosting their wildly
popular podcast syntax fm here live
today um and we are you know as as usual
on syntax live wes and scott get super
interactive with their audience so we
are excited to allow the rest of the
conference to also
but unfortunately here on the stage
where you've been watching these great
talks all day we have about a 20-second
delay with the broadcast so it's not the
best for audience interaction so uh we
are all going to migrate
over to the sessions tab
tab here somewhere on the left of your
screen um to watch syntax live and for
everybody tuning in on the youtube
channel on free code camp's youtube
channel you will be able to see it live
but it'll again have a little bit of a
delay for that live broadcast
but first before you go we want to thank
you all for being here and experiencing
this very unique version of react-a-thon
with us
if you missed any of the talks you'll be
able to find all the recordings in about
a week on the react-a-thon youtube
channel
and from the main virtual stage here at
react-a-thon
anjana and myself are signing off
yes we uh we have had an amazing time
with you all these last few days thank
you so much for joining us and for
having us as your mcs um it has been an
absolute pleasure so once again uh we
are just thrilled that everyone could
come together here and especially since
it was the first edition of react-a-thon
in the cloud react-a-thon on the webs
coming at you through your screen so we
hope fingers crossed by this time next
year maybe we can all uh
be in person uh again and if not then
then sometime in the near future we hope
to see you all here in san francisco so
i've been angina vacheel a developer
advocate at observable and thank you so
much for having us
and with me here
and i'm jonathan catrell i am a director
of technology at pbs also host of
developer t
and this has been so wonderful let's
enjoy a jam-packed hour of syntax
with wes boss and scott telinski
i almost did the scary voice again
welcome to syntax everybody
spooky
uh thanks so much for everybody for
tuning in my name is oh no we have
slides for this um welcome scott how you
doing
you guys get
a look behind the scenes of how
unprepared we are
you didn't even clap you put your hands
up you put your hands up and i put my
hands up and i was like oh we're gonna
clap no clap all right let's do the club
ready three two
one
that was the best cop we've ever done
not for me
awesome well uh let's let's get into it
thanks everybody for coming out this is
super fun we've got a lot of interaction
today so uh make sure that you're glued
to the chat and we also have um some q a
and some stuff we got links coming up in
just a sec
yeah
uh so to answer your question from a
minute ago i'm doing good wes i'm doing
i'm doing very good uh those of you who
are listening on the podcast this is uh
being uh originally recorded uh at
react-a-thon 2020
so shout out to
uh everybody who's listening into a post
fact but uh this is this is going down
live right now uh how do we want to kick
this off wes
i think let's let's get into intros and
uh
and then we'll we'll get into the show
yeah
well okay so uh for those of you who
have never heard of syntax we are a
twice a weekly podcast and on mondays we
have
30 minute or shorter episodes we like to
call hasty treats
and on
uh wednesdays we've got tasty treats
that is our hour long um screenshot and
scott you got your cursor in the middle
of the slide
i
man you always drive the slides i don't
uh it's true yeah no that's my problem
because i could have css cursor none on
that when you're in full screen mode
with the css there's css for full screen
right i could have cursored none it so
my bad
you should have added print styles as
well for instance
i actually have done print styles before
because i wanted to
uh export my slides to a pdf so i could
upload them so we do printers for our
invoices
oh that's i actually have done that as
well yeah it's worth it uh my name is
scott talinski i'm a developer from
denver colorado you can find me at
s-t-o-l-i-n-s-k-i
uh on just about everywhere uh instagram
for dance moves and twitter for
code moves
my name is wes boss i'm a full stack dev
from canada
i tweet most recently fleet until they
shut it down um and instagram at west
boston no they're not but
it's uh
it's not taking off as well as i thought
it would so we'll see
my fleet
all right what do we got next so today
is a live podcast what do we got on the
gamut
next slide please scott
next slide
it's weird not being able to control the
slides
um yeah so
we're gonna have all i want for
christmas and react
js or nay s where you have to decide if
the library that we're referring to is a
real javascript library or uh if it's
not if it's fake if we made it up or if
it's
uh potentially something else as well as
a javascript library
we've got underrated versus overrated
where scott and i talk about
hotness you hear about often and we're
gonna give our opinion of whether you
should spend your time on it or not
we're also going to be doing a fun game
that we prepared and i'm actually really
excited about this one because we have
not talked a whole lot about it but
we're doing something called syntax
error where wes and i are going to
uh throw up a code that has a small
error in it somewhere and we're going to
have to try to find it without uh code
styling or anything like that
we've got uh javascript hot take tweets
that's all i say about that for now
javascript take tweets and we also have
q and a
with scott and wes the q is is me and
the a is wes in this one for the q a
we've got a link um so uh if you have a
question you'd like us to answer um go
to pigeonhole.a t forward slash tasty
um and that will there's two things on
there we're gonna we're gonna play a
little polling game in just a sec and
then there's also a q a you can you can
add your questions in there so um if
you've got something already throw it in
there um and you can upload the good
ones and whatnot
yeah
so
let's get into the content here uh the
first thing we're going to be doing is
all i want for christmas in react is and
these are fun things and if you think
some of these things should not be added
to react that's cool uh i think these
are just sort of some things that maybe
we've seen either elsewhere or just
things that we think could be better
that we really like i would love to see
it react
so the first one um i think this is be
on top of a lot of people's lists would
be suspense for data fetching uh you
know there's just an endless amount of
jokes you could make about being in
suspense about suspense but i'm not
going to go there
once you use suspense for data fetching
or at least give it a little try uh it's
really nice to use uh and i would love
to to see more of this but man yeah i
think we're just gonna be waiting for a
little while
yeah i don't know um i just wish that we
knew what the status of what it was um
or like i know they're they're trying to
spend their time um to see like make
sure that they make the right choices
and and the best approach and we have
all this like possible server streaming
stuff that's coming so i'm pretty
interested to see what comes of that
next one we have here is mountain
unmount animations um there's just this
is a general theme for me in react is
that um
i look over at it's that meme where i
look over at some of these other
frameworks
that looks nice like i kind of wish that
a lot of the stuff was just built in and
you didn't have to use third-party
library i wish there was just like a
first-party way to do this this type of
stuff and i don't even do a lot of
animations i don't scot you do lots
right yeah i do lots and in specifically
the um
the mount the unmounting animation bit
kills me so many times because like if
you're nested deeply and you want to
control like the delay like even a point
three second delay on unmounting a
component it's kind of difficult to like
really orchestrate that uh and it's not
like it's not doable
we have things but if you are several
components deep and you want to unmount
the parent component orchestrating
something nested like that
not not super duper easy to do still
this next one i'll let you take because
i know this is your your baby yeah well
okay so i would like to see single file
components which like it doesn't
necessarily say that i need single file
components and really what that is is
the idea that you have a file um and the
framework can understand a little bit
more about the application or that
specific component just by the nature of
the fact that it's in a file
the obvious example of this would be
something like a style tag in a spell
file a style tag in a spell file
automatically scopes the css within that
file to that component and the amount of
js you could save typing just by having
writing a little style tag below your
component and having it just work a
little sprinkling of uh magical uh
rock salt what do do you
have any fancy salts we have a volcano
which is black
really no we have um
what's the the flaky salt in diamonds
yes diamond
what is that stuff courtney just bought
it i sick picked it on the podcast
before mal don't yell don't um and we
you we bought like on amazon you can buy
like a bucket of it and last summer i
bought a bunch of salt cellars which is
like a little
wooden
thing with the lid on it and um i gave
everybody in my family a salt cellar
with the the salt in it it was an
awesome gift super cheap
and uh it's got a nice little stocking
stuffer so yeah for you i would take a
salt flight uh add a little bit to my uh
component files and and have single file
components there
uh next one we have here is prevent
default shortcuts um just like
one of these little things like if there
was a syntax
for handling events
that was like star equals i think i
don't even know maybe i think another i
saw this in another framework a lot of
them
yeah so what's the smell syntax for that
you just uh you can you can just tell it
to
to ignore the prevent default like
directly on the
on the component via a directive i
forget what the syntax is offhand
star like on click or
handle change star equals and it like
immediately default prevents the default
on that that would be kind of cool yeah
and i'm really trying to i'm really
trying to limit the amount of times i
say spelled here on my promise
jonathan says this is a smeltadon it's
true maybe we just need to
um move over
what do we got next here um form input
state um to mapping yeah i just think
like like forms in react like that like
everybody uses forms in their react
application or almost everybody does and
it wouldn't it be great if there was
some sort of like built-in thing like i
remember back to the angular days i
still remember like it just like you
just like ng bind and you give it a
piece of state and it just sinks in like
oh my gosh and like if it's a number it
will parse float or parse into it um
there's i know there's lots of libraries
out there whenever i talk about forms
and everyone's like oh have you heard of
formic before i'm like yes i heard a
format in like it's awesome but like i
wish react would be
uh default have all that stuff baked in
for you when i look at like formic code
it's like this is no less complex than
just writing all the state updaters
myself um
and that's not what i'm looking for i'm
not looking for complete i mean yes i
want complete control but i'm not
looking for
endless fine tunability i'm looking for
do it all for me um and that
that can be nice i actually ended up
even writing my own form library because
i didn't like any of them and and it's
still not great and maintaining your own
formal library kind of sucks
in itself so like
yeah i there there has to be a better
way than than making controlled state
for each individual each individual or
reducer or whatever there has to be a
better way
um
now we're going to be kicking off
something that we like to call js or
nay s
and this is going to be a fun little
game where we shout out a library title
or potential library title and you tell
us if it's a javascript library an
object of which we're going to define or
both
uh so we've done this a couple of times
on our live shows and it's one of our
favorite games so we gotta keep coming
back to it so you gotta head to
pigeonhole.at forward slash tasty or
scan the qr code in the slides here and
it will get us up and
running let me bounce on over to
yeah
we got 19 people in there right now
25 west do you see the slides or do you
see pigeon hole on your end right now i
see pigeon hole yeah
so click through to the js or nas you
bet
36
42 how many people should we wait for we
got two
122 watching on there and got another
164 on youtube
so
[Music]
let's let's see how many we wait for
you are currently
[Music]
oh and now it's going up
going up i think it's i think that's the
youtube delay right there skyrocketing
let's let's wait till we go to a hundred
so
[Music]
what are you sipping on with
i'm sipping on uh young rival
it's uh
strong ipa in canada if a beer is over
like 5.2 percent it must legally say
strong beer on it which is funny because
it's like like like laughs in german you
know like yeah
yeah i don't know if i ever told you
this story but we went to montreal for
my brother's bachelor party and we were
like we were like oh yeah bad flip party
right and so we went to the store to get
a bunch of beer and we were all sipping
on these beers and i had like maybe like
three beers and i was like what is going
on i do not even i do not even feel
tipsy at all and we look and they're
like two percent beers and we were
basically just like hydrating ourselves
the whole time uh yeah it was a lot like
utah it was very funny we were just like
oh what so we had this giant case of two
percent beers that we had to go through
it was it was ridiculous
that's hilarious all right 91 let's
start it there ready start it i'm ready
start quiz all right so
is
graphene uh
carbon atoms organized in a hexagonal
lattice
or
an oh go ahead sorry i forgot how we do
this go ahead this is the flow west come
on or an opinionated python library for
building graphql libraries
oh i forgot to delete that in python all
right i thought i thought it deleted the
np or both or both
of them
wow
wow they're flying in now yeah
i can see the answers right now
all right we're going to reveal the
answer
both
it is both so i looked it up
what graphene was and it's when carbon
atoms are organized in a specific way
kind of interesting wikipedia read
next up we have floodlight is it a super
simple syntax highlighter for xhtml
documents
a large light used to illuminate dark
outdoor spaces
or both
i think we're getting people on this one
scott it's fun to see the the answers i
get to see the answer streaming in by
the way shout out to pigeonhole um they
make this awesome
like conference software where you can
do like live polling like we are doing
right now and um
it's awesome like we checked out
probably five or six different pieces of
software
and uh i think i want to have the one of
their devs on
the podcast just because of how
super fast and like slick it is yeah all
right ready
reveal answer
oh
man holy three point seven percent of
you got it correct it's literally both
white i think you might have
to goof this one oh yeah so obviously
it's both so i keep that up
but it's only not only 40 percent of you
got it right
it's not a light to eliminate dark
spaces it is it is
oh man all right next
machine
is this an early 2000s skate brand
or a view based gui for creating state
machines
or both
[Music]
hello
i'm seeing i'm watching the youtube chat
and everyone's like wait a floodlight
literally
the original description for that one
was a literal floodlight
and i was like i changed it yeah
oh man that is good
all right here we go answer
boom 51 of you were correct it is an
early 2000's escape front although that
would be a good name for it it's like
totally believable it's so unbelievable
a view based gui for creating state
machines oh believable yeah
all right next
next joplin
is this a free open source note taking
and to do application based on markdown
so i got cut off there
a city in the northwestern corner of
missouri
or both
they are streaming right in
streaming
i like all the skaters in the chat are
like toy machine
yeah one of my favorite skater skates
for toy machine
all right ready reveal
really wait hold on who's your favorite
skater
uh his daniel uh man
his last name's really hard to pronounce
daniel daniel live
like i always want to say leviathan
amazing
i'll check them out are you ready i'll
share them with you
both 50.9 percent of you guessed it is
both i didn't even know this i was just
looking for um i went on github's like
trending repos and i saw joplin and i
was like oh i wonder what joplin is and
i also figured out like it's a wicked
markdown
um app well they're like you know we
were talking about like how i can't take
markdown
notes on my phone and like have them
sync to just files on my computer yeah
um looks like this
does that
oh
something else for that
what is that do you remember i'm very
curious because i'm my eyes right now my
phone is currently dead so oh yeah scott
poor scott
this is the new weekly segment what
piece of technology is broken with scott
right now dude i can't even like my
iphone stopped working just out of the
blue it started looping
and i'm uh gotta send it off i have no
idea what's going on with my tech no
idea
all right all right next one no is this
a javascript library that connects to no
code tools
like uh what was this one um
bubble the i o
i didn't realize that
or is it a smart 12 volt car battery
changer charger or both
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
all right ready
oh
this one was very split uh this is a
carvel that and in fact i was uh my
battery just died because i haven't
driven my car in like nine months and i
didn't drip feed it uh so
i was like looking at battery stuff on
amazon and that's where i found the noco
uh that's how we uh come up with these
questions here so you gotta say 37.8
percent voted the correct answer we
gotta say it for our audio only
listeners audio only yep next one we
have here is inner is it an internet of
things smart light bulb
or a css in js library for selecting
parent selectors
and unfortunately this one cannot be
both
this is a good one i kind of like not
having both but both like at least you
can throw people
yeah both is definitely the wild card in
my mind because it adds that little bit
of like
well could it be
yeah
all right
oh
it was the internet of things smart
light bulb
which is funny about this is because i
actually sick pick the inner bulbs on an
upcoming episode and i was like wait
when is that episode airing did i uh did
i
ruin my uh
my uh
js or nas oh yeah you're sick
next one is cap coma strand is it a
thermoplastic carbon fiber composite rod
used in
modern building
or a redux-like state management library
for svelt
or both
wow i'm about to get them votes let's
just say i'm surprised that's this one
i think i think it's safe to say that
you're surprised about all of them so
far
i thought this one would have got people
it's not getting people people know what
this is do you know what this is people
got got or people did not get got they
did not get got on this one not all
do i know what this is i'm gonna guess
it's a thermoplastic carbon fiber
composite rod used in modern buildings
but i'm not quite sure
all right reveal
yes almost 77 of you guessed correctly
that's an odd thing to know
that
it is a thermoplastic carbon fiber
composite rod i think most people could
look at this and say there's no way
that's an actual thing and that it's
most likely a thermoplastic carbon fiber
composite rod
oh man all right next one
sputnik five
sputnik v
uh is this a code name for an upcoming
wordpress release
with the build
the built-in headlights
in headless
getting that cut off
yeah they're getting cut off i think
that's a
i thought i had them all in there maybe
it's a
limitation of this thing or is it a
non-replicating viral vector covet 19
vaccine
it's funny because we should be we
should be voting on the ones that the
other person wrote because yeah okay
so you
tell me what you think it is
i think that this is the wordpress thing
okay i think people are googling it
because it was very much skewed in the
early days to the wrong one and now it's
it's going up all right ready
it is 45 percent of you guessed
correctly it's a non-replicating viral
vector covid19 vaccine but 44 of you
thought it was a a code name for
upcoming wordpress release um
it's not though because wordpress only
uses jazz musicians for their uh code
names
well
who doesn't know that
okay
oh that's good people in the chat are
saying how many they got right one out
of eight
all right
the highest score was me
i bet that person the highest score
person probably picked both for
floodlight and was like
yeah yeah you know what so there was
there's two people that got all of them
cracked because obviously i goofed up
the headlight one but that was fun that
was fun
awesome all right thanks for tuning in
let's jump back to the slides now yeah
sorry it's for some reason when i go out
of or when i go into full screen i have
to go
like back
i have to go out of full screen all
right so
uh
next thing we're going to be doing is
talking overrated and underrated and
this is sort of like a a segment where
we're just kind of gauging each other's
interests or ideas on some of these new
tech things
so let's kick it off with the very first
one is dino overrated or underrated i'm
gonna say right now
it's probably underrated it's very nice
to work in um
i think the permissions model of it all
is very uh very forward-thinking i think
the entire
import via url is not as painful as i
expected it to be
overall the typescript experience with
it not having to run a bundler not have
to do any of that was just
very nice it's very nice to use and i
like that all of their tooling is sort
of
um
well what's the reason what's the
reasonable way to say this not all over
the place it's not a total mess so uh i
like it
yeah i i think it's i'm gonna say
underrated as well um not to say that
you're going to build your next app on
it because that would that would
probably be not a good idea
because it's very much in the early days
yeah um but there's there's like a lot
of and you probably have heard this on
the podcast we've been talking a lot
about shifting
um tooling right now we've been talking
a lot about esm becoming
the thing now that it's in node uh we've
been talking about modules and urls
we're talking about typescript um and
dino seems to just nail all of those
things um
and that's really cool um will it
replace node i don't i don't think so
maybe it would you would see it coming
for like in like five years like it's
not like we're gonna wake up tomorrow
and be like oh my gosh i'm i have no
skills left and like that's the other
thing about it is that if you know
javascript and you're in node like you
switch over to dino no problem um but
it's it's kind of cool and i'm very
curious to see how
node will react to this but also it's
it's harder for node to just do this
stuff because
they have to maintain compatibility with
the rest of the node that's why esm in
node was so hard to get right because
they couldn't break
10 years worth of work that they've done
whereas dino could just be like all
right brand new thing here we go
uh next one is on the uh sort of
somewhat related is esm import
from url and
i think this one is very very
um very good
in fact it only took me a little bit to
this is underrated i would say i think
importing anything from
url is really pretty underrated overall
because
it is to me one of the
the fastest ways to try out a file i
know that when we were trying out stuff
with ts in um dino it was like so nice
to be able oh let's just import this
file from a url
yeah just in general importing from a
url and being able to access the file as
an import like that very very good
yeah i think so too as well like first
you can do that in literally you can do
it in javascript in the browser um which
is super cool that you can just like you
you can write an app have a html file
script tag type of module
and then just start importing stuff from
different urls that are out there
and i think that's pretty cool i don't
know how i feel about
um upgrading like what happens when you
upgrade like a bump of version release
i'm sure there will be tools around that
um because like you you literally import
it from like whatever cdn.com forward
slash
v2
v2.2.0 and then what happens when two
point zero point one comes out do you
like find and replace
um do you have to copy paste that in dna
and there's orandino there's a uh
uh
like a like a standard of doing like a
depths folder depth.ts where you do your
imports and that sort of almost becomes
a package.json if you think about it
okay but it's just with import
statements uh so that's definitely a
thing there are there are detractors
from that but uh it seems like that's
what we taught in our dino course so
like it seems to be pretty much of a
like a standard in that world so who
knows maybe that becomes a thing
so you have like a depth.js file where
you import everything you need for the
project yes and then you and then is it
global or
it's almost like a package.json because
you're setting the version when you're
importing it and then you're yeah you
want to up the version you're only
modifying it in one spot oh
that makes so much sense yeah because
you can even inside but yeah you can use
the export from syntax for that or you
say like
export react from http whatever and what
that does is it imports it and exports
it in the same go oh that makes so much
i don't i didn't think of it that's
awesome yeah it's nice
uh next one is remix dot run wes do you
want to take this one first
yeah um this is the new uh react
framework for building apps and websites
from ryan florence michael jackson uh
two
of the devs or the devs behind react
router awesome react uh thought leaders
in the space uh and they are sort of
like taking a look at the landscape and
and rethinking it and um it's it's
closed right now and i think it will be
you have to pay for it um but from what
i've seen it seems really interested so
i'm going to go
underrated on this one and not that
we're going to everybody's going to be
using it but i think that they are
rethinking a lot of things especially
with
um i've what i've heard is that
streaming from the server and this pain
that we have which is server side and
client-side rehydration and whatnot um
i'm very curious to see and i bet if
they like nail something like i bet
other frameworks will adopt that as well
yeah we're we're pretty much all going
when we're agreeing on everything i
think i think it's
underrated uh i also think that like
that like you said specifically about
the streaming from server side uh yeah
and that stuff sounds so good to me uh i
i maintain our own server side rendered
react application and
it's not a lot of fun um it's just not
it's not super easy but it also feels
like it also feels like it's doing more
work than it needs to and i think the
remix folks are really figuring a lot of
those aspects out um next one's gonna be
x-state which believe it or not uh i'm
gonna say it's underrated
yeah that actually might have been a
problem in our approach to this but uh
x-state hey uh i don't know if you've
used state machines at all west but when
we were writing the video player for or
the video uploading system so we upload
our videos to all of those who have not
uh heard we use a service called mux to
do our video so we upload our videos to
bucks and building that a video uploader
was like the thing that made me see the
light for state machines specifically
because there were so many states that
this uploader could possibly be in and
so for me it was uh
pretty eye-opening to control those
states in the uh state machines world
for the first time and just say like all
right i really feel like this uploader
is really solid compared to some of my
other code which was mostly boolean
flags said by state variables and things
like that
i've not used it so i'm gonna go medium
rated but uh it's one of those things
that you just can't hear people stop
talking about it and we had david on the
podcast six months ago and he talked
about it and it
it just made a lot of sense like i
certainly had the problems that it
solves
yeah um i think we should skip a couple
because
we're uh we're running a little low on
time so let's you want to move to the um
lighthouse scores or no code
rated
no
no code it's overrated i don't want to
lose my job no code overrated yes render
props overrated render props overrated
underrated thunder
lighthouse
overrated rated they're fine
okay
uh now we're going to get into a really
fun one that we're calling syntax error
and this one is so much fun that wes and
i have really not consulted on this
beforehand uh so this could be a total
mess so syntax error is we are going to
be showing each other code with no
syntax highlighting and the other person
must find out what's going wrong with it
uh and we initially had some idea of
like point
point giving points based on a time
timer but let's just see how fast we can
do it let's and uh for those of you who
are watching along i have no pl please
go ahead and try to solve these on your
yourself as well but i have no clue how
dastardly wes has chosen to be and i'm
really
see
i was i was like
do i want to do i want to work in what
do i wanna do here okay give me the code
scott first one yeah let's do it first
one is for wes
how do you find the bug in this code and
no you do not have to know the libraries
involved animated from frame promotion
portal modal from utilities okay
const there's there's a no error
no no no no no that's not it no i see
the arrow
don't look at the chat because somebody
spoiled it in the chat no i'm not
looking at the chat
uh is accent max width equals you got
back ticks on that sucker that's fine
um
yeah that's fine okay uh return portal
animate
presence portal
this is one that you will this this is a
common bug
close close action is being run on mount
not on the closed event
you are right
yes
all right
ten points for me next one scott for you
for me
okay
kant's okay i gotta not look at the chat
okay we got
an array with an object
name string properties okay that all
looks fine to me
i see that you are using uh semicolons
here so that's a no i'm just kidding um
so your destructuring name
oh man this one is dastardly okay this
one is this is not hold on we should say
this is not something you should do but
it is valid javascript except for the
part that's the syntax error
i can you use a property uh parts 0
before you yeah
you can just declare you can destructure
a value and then create a renaming
no no we're creating new variables based
on the previously destructured values i
didn't know you could do that okay i
know nobody knows that that's
you know what it's handy for is if you
have want to get the uh last item in the
first item of an array you can say like
uh you can destructure the length from
an array and then i think i know what
the error is by the way is it that
you're giving me is that you're just
returning first and last in the object
and not returning the object itself
yes that is it it's there is missing
parentheses around
the curly brackets
right now there
now that
all right this one
oh my gosh
oh my gosh god this is a
comp series form
playlist
oh man even typed it
oh yeah this is sorry this is typescript
i tried to remove any of the typescript
stuff that's fine
you state
if there's a playlist author id
i would consider this one desperately
but um
is it it's a syntax error right like not
like a
it's um it this code will not work it
will it will run but it won't work
i'm gonna have to go to the chat for
this one this one
uh the props could be defined somewhere
else no
sorry problem
this is the type script though i i
should oh
you state is not imported
no i'm sorry that's not it no that's
right come on come on
all right tell me what it is the actual
i mean i'm sorry the actual error here
is that a select list does not have an
options
oh i was gonna say that i don't want to
look like an idiot like i didn't know it
yeah so select list does not have an
options property uh the everything else
was sort of just that noise yeah
everything else is nice okay next one
here
for me okay function
function okay you spelled that correctly
uh
three url i always look for that i feel
like you're going to do something like
that okay
const
i would never do something like that i'm
going to pull the graph at you and say
use ref is not defined okay um
okay right that your
podcast component isn't outside of
something you're just
so the first is the function definition
and then below it is using it using it
mp3 url is equal to here's a string okay
audio
this is closed audio ref use ref
uh controls hell yeah target set volume
e set valley parts
the volume is equal to volume
range oh this one is difficult for me to
find
um
use state good one
set box isn't it is it funny how
dependent we are on like people used to
be like oh just use notepad for coding
but how dependent we are on for silly
little mistakes i use my uh yeah my my
styling a whole bunch
you want to know it
i
yeah now that
the audio source says mp3 uri
that killed it see that to me is
dastardly i don't think that that to me
is destroyed
yeah i tried to use like a lot of like
uh distractions because kind of ref done
right and things like that
yeah okay all right here's a uh here's a
good one for you s so buckle up
all right
import wrap from react import link from
rack router dom postcard post style link
you have a nested component called card
if link return
link to
where is the bug
at least i didn't taunt you in this one
what kind of bug is that
um it's a react bug
uh you can't
uh maybe you can
you're passing the prop with like a
object and a string in it what are you
talking about or no not objects are the
curly brackets with the string in you
can do that though right
usually when i do it that way it's back
text but i don't see why a single
quotes like the color on the author card
uh the color on the author card no
that's fine
that's just that's that's uh that's a
misdirection is what that is that's what
we call that i see i see what you're
doing there okay um
it's just to say hey uh you probably
don't write like this very often
the style's missing double curly
brackets yeah you're not passing an
object to style on the the link you're
right so in for those of you who are
watching and paying attention on the
link component here we used a style
property and then just passed in some
a property and a value but there was no
containing
that's a good one yeah yep yep so
they're all fairly oh i got one more ooh
okay yeah sorry i wasn't in the mindset
i got a
oh
this is this is just one liner
um i mean i know what the bug is uh
there's a bug here the the yeah the the
date get full year is like a space
between it is that correct
that is wrong that is valid javascript
did you know that it's like that yeah it
works try it new date space docket full
year isn't that weird i don't want to
try that and i have no idea why that
would work in that
uh really because
see that's
yeah i don't know why actually that is
dastardly okay
what a year
um so you have the opening and closing
curlies oh you got an extra curly two
curly yep nailed it
that's good in that isn't that a good um
distraction though with the space it's
perfect distraction because nobody's
ever seen that nobody ever sees that
yeah
this is pretty good
all right we'll move into some hot cake
tweets
i asked on twitter
for some hot take tweets what are your
javascript hot take tweets um and
everybody gave me their opinions which
is hilarious because my like twitter's
been
ruined for like three days now uh with
people sending me because not because
like people do it but people reply with
their hot take and then there's like a
every single tweet has like a 40 thread
argument behind it so the first one is
uh from l'oreal tech spread syntax isn't
super readable and you probably should
use something else if you can have it
yes i just shared an advent of code
solution using it so sue me so i really
like this one because
um
this has i do it myself but it's not
super readable um how take tweet what do
you what's your take on the scott
i think it's wrong
i don't know
this is gonna bug me because i'm the the
type of person who does want to go on to
twitter and be like no that's wrong like
it doesn't matter uh in fact but i i
agree with laurie that like when i
when i don't want to say i don't want to
try to claim that she just started using
them because i doubt she has but like um
when i first started using them
personally i i felt like
this is not readable but like now that
i'm i i've been to the edge and back and
i've been using them for so long and i
understand yeah
like i i see through it for some reason
i've i've been able to see through the
lines of the matrix and now i just like
it a lot but
once you know what spread is then like
you obviously have to know what it is
but
uh but once you know it's the best it's
the yeah
it can definitely
be a little much uh next one is from
chris hellman
you missed one
ah no
keep going we're running out of time go
to go to the
okay next one is from chris gilman
console.log is lazy and slows you down
as a terrible debugging experience uh
chris can be right about all of this and
i will still use console.log until i
enter the grave
so uh yeah no debugger is great debugger
is fantastic but sometimes it crashes my
browser and sometimes it's slower than
using deep or just a simple console log
and seen actually
like i we did a show on syntax about
like advanced debugging techniques with
like people ask me what else do you use
break points um break on you can you can
listen for dom changes
um all of that stuff
uh you can view network requests and all
that um those are great and i use those
when i'm when i'm in trouble but nothing
wrong with the console log i love a good
console log
optional chaining makes code so much
more readable and makes it harder to
debug when it comes to optional props or
fields
i love optional chaining
it's my baby and i will defend it i've
not run into a really odd bug because
that's the thing is like it could be
undefined anywhere along your chain and
you wouldn't necessarily know where
it was undefined unless you took them
out
um but you could also just pop a break
point in there or log the thing one step
above see
what is coming in what's funny is that i
uh once i moved to typescript it made me
realize just how unsafe some of my code
was and like sometimes the solution is
if you're in a conditional just dropping
a question mark in there to do the
optional chaining and it's like all
right now this is uh safe i'm it's gonna
work i don't have to worry about it ever
again
uh this next one is from dan dan says
javascript really isn't that bad as long
as you avoid double equals and four dot
dot in uh yeah dan is dead on javascript
is really not that bad and it's gotten
better all the time
a lot of the people i think who
criticize it or even criticize the the
changes on them
are maybe people who came from other
languages they're using javascript and
it all feels like hectic and chaotic at
this point uh and it is kind of chaotic
but once you get in it you got it and uh
you know i really i really enjoy working
in javascript now typescript for the
most part big fan um double equals i
don't use it so one of the other hot
ticks was double equals is fine
yeah uh and the other uh for in yeah use
four of instead i was added to the
language a couple years ago and it's
awesome yeah it's worth it
next one is the npm ecosystem has turned
javascript development into a game of
legos rather than real programming and
to that i say
i'm a lego master i wouldn't be able to
build some of the stuff i build without
some of the packages from some much
smarter people that's the beauty of
javascript is that you can reach for
these much harder things
uh like oauth implementations and be
crypt um when you don't necessarily have
to do it i wouldn't know how to build
that myself you know as real programmers
they mold their own legos out of their
plastic that they have forged
from the oils of the earth
yeah i i don't know about this one yeah
i mean that's all for unless you're
unless you're writing like a binary
everything you're doing is the exact
same as what you're saying npm is
um okay
react is the worst choice for beginners
doubly so in its current state
yeah i kind of agree it's it's it's it's
not the worst choice for beginners
because uh it's so widely used that's
why it's a good choice for beginners
it's so widely used you can get a job
it's good on your resume right but if
you are just trying to understand dumb
events and whatever man uh keep it
vanilla and if and if you uh want to
move into a framework i don't know keep
into something way easier than that
yeah that's so for beginners listening
let's not say you shouldn't learn react
i literally have a course called react
for beginners um
but there are there's a handful of
things you need to know about react you
couldn't be able to just jump in but i
think that's the same for a lot of stuff
so i think i agree on this but
you could still learn it it's it's still
not not super hard and complicated
there's just more you got to have like a
list of like five gotchas you know it's
also part of like saying like pancakes
are the worst food for breakfast they're
still pancakes man like they're pretty
dope
yeah next one aaron
bushnell says if you work at an agency
really try to avoid using um using
things until it's absolutely necessary
and even then only what you need when
you manage hundreds of sites it quickly
can become
a tremendous source of technical debt i
agree as somebody who still has a
coffeescript site in uh production and
what
six or seven i've been working this year
to convert all my gulp sites over
the world are you saying
it's i'm not writing it anymore but like
it's it's still running and it still
runs good
um but uh yeah you definitely that's the
beauty i loved doing agency work and
freelance work because you could choose
whatever you wanted but you can
definitely fall into a hole um if you
start using you just bring on a whole
bunch of stuff it's the same thing with
wordpress plugins too if you go bonkers
on wordpress plugins you're going to
have a bad time because half those
things are going to be out of date or
not maintained or break they're going to
wait for you to bigquery
yeah
uh what do we got next do we want to get
into q a because yeah yeah let's move
into q and a we're running out of time
here yeah because we've been going
forever
100 more of these
yeah some good ones some good ones go
visit that tweet and listen to all the
popular and popular pages so um if
you've got a question for us um go to
pigeonhole.at forward slash tasty
um
and ask a question or you can you can
drop it in the chat as well um or
wherever you
you would like to to do that let me open
up my admin board here
all right i've got
one here
first question is from anonymous if
you've recently started doing web dev
work which career path would you choose
startup
fang fang is facebook amazon
uh what's the other apple
uh netflix and google yeah right you
need to actually start making up like a
fake fang with like different companies
in here yeah it's bored
uh
yeah that would be hilarious uh yeah so
would you choose startup fang or slash
big tech companies or freelance or
contractor if i started today
um
it depends um
i
for me i look at some startups and i
don't envy
the work life balance and the grind and
and how quickly things move um but i
also know people who get into startups
and they're they're young and they've
got
nothing but time and and whatnot um
certainly easier and i also not not to
say that startups are only for young
people because there's there's lots of
people that are running
um
great startups they just work nine to
five and they're done right but i think
on the flip side there's also a very
heavy culture in that fang
um i really like studio work a lot
yeah like that that's an option to
working in a design dev studio because
you get a lot of experience with many
different projects and especially
earlier on in your career um
it can give you a lot of exposure to
different projects in working with
clients many times you're you're in
client meetings yourself rather than you
know being some project manager so you
can get some managerial skills you can
get some uh you know some project skills
that shift very rapidly
um
i also i'm gonna say
if you can get the fang job go for it um
just don't allow your lifestyle to
inflate what they're paying you um
because it's very scary to be making two
hundred thousand dollars
um at facebook and before you know it
like someone's gotta pay for that tesla
and if you get sick of if you get sick
of working at a fang and you want to go
do your own thing like i get dms like
this all the time people like oh wes i
want to i want to make courses like you
do i want to be able to just dick around
on the internet like you do um and
uh so like that would look so good on
your resume like i work for google and
now i'm doing my own thing x googler
makes a new um product or whatever i
think that would be kind of cool so if
you can get it go for it um otherwise
i'm a big fan of like scottish studio i
went contract freelance my own and it
worked out for me i really enjoyed it
yeah yeah i agree
uh uh eric real quick before we do the
next one ask in the chat about uh
breakdancing being added to the paris
olympics i have been following the
breaking in the olympics thing for maybe
like 15 years now maybe longer than that
they've been the the group that's behind
it a lot of people have been trying to
get it in since the literal 80s so um
i'm very excited the the junior olympics
for went really well you know a lot of
the the people in the scene are
concerned about it becoming exploited by
the masses or whatever but to be honest
the junior olympics went so well and
they didn't really change it too much so
i'm pumped uh this uh anon says
typescript all the things and
yeah i'm pretty much in i'm pretty much
in uh i i really like it and i don't see
myself writing anything else even like
today i popped open a quick utility and
i um would typically
if i'm firing up a quick code utility
i'm going to hit up just some some you
know off the cuff js kind of like real
quick stuff and i did it in typescript
and it didn't i wasn't any more
encumbered than i was in javascript like
i felt i felt like i could flow with it
and um and that to me was like a big
thing because i always see typescript as
this big barrier to entry you've got to
set up your tooling and whatever but as
long as you're using the right kind of
systems that make it easy to get going
and typescript all the things yeah
i we were talking about this we had a
topic table on typescript yesterday and
i joined in and we were talking about
like is it a barrier to entry anymore
and i don't think so because like um
pretty much every major or even minor
package out there i have a one line
uh line code called weight and somebody
submitted types where they all have
types already um
you you can infer types for like like i
just built right before this podcast i
was like man i want to see my webcam but
the like apple
photo booth they crop it to like like
this
um so i was like i built like a it's
called check my hair and it's just it
just shows your webcam really quickly
and i i'm like all right build this and
type script and like the the number of
line it was like maybe 40 lines of code
and there was two or three spots where i
had to literally type something and
everything else was inferred and you got
all the benefits from the the code
completions and all that so um like i
don't think everything no you can still
write really good javascript but
um i think the barrier to typescript has
become very low in the last year or so
that's specifically why i'm into it now
because you can get up and running even
for silly projects super quickly
word
uh
next one you wanna grab it
what do you do to keep up to date with
the latest and greatest changes in tech
front end libraries new languages etc um
hey here's actually um
do you have the github app on your phone
wes
um
no i don't get it do i
the github official app uh let me see
pop it open here
this is
uh it's so good for finding new packages
there's an explore tab on it and it
gives you a bunch of potential libraries
that you might be interested in yeah
explore there we go and i use this like
crazy for finding stuff i don't know how
or why but um
this to me like has really changed how i
find projects because it shows you
trending stuff and whatever but it's
very good and i use it all the time to
find new things i also uh look at
awesome awesome repos you'll find things
that like awesome script and then you
just go down the line of list and look
for cool stuff um just look for for neat
little things so that's what i do
personally
next question we have here is what do
you do to keep up to date with the
latest and
i read that i've read that sorry that i
read and answered oh yeah obviously
answered that um for me
it's we can't ask this question all the
time it's um follow you follow people on
twitter who who follow this stuff um
like scott and i listen to syntax um and
like what do scott and i actually do um
i read i read release notes of every
single browser um i will anytime there's
like a working group that changes a
proposal
um there is a good twitter account
called intent to ship
which is really good which means that
like that at that point it's going to be
in the browser in a couple weeks so
um just like kind of watch those and
you don't have to it's not like you're
going to miss something if you listen to
the podcast and follow
a handful of good people on twitter
you're going to hear about subgrid 14
times and the 15th time that you hear it
that's when you should probably pay
attention because okay now now it's the
thing i need to implement in my uh in my
app
speaking of cool new things uh
i saw adam oh no uh not adam um oona
tweeted this out houdini.how today
oh yeah
houdini.how very cool stuff for css
houdini um so i posted in the chat so
let me go and check that out all right
uh
wow big wallet questions here yeah they
came in we got
how much time left no time let's let's
just keep going until they kick us off
um
what what other good questions we got
here can you share some exclusive
barbecue tips
fish sauce did you did your mom try the
fish sauce she did yeah she made it
right my mom was like i'm making the
recipe and i'm like what recipe and
she's like the one from the podcast that
wes was talking about so it's very fun
uh yeah she made it no she loved it and
um
we do something very similar to that all
the time we use fish sauce pretty pretty
heavy-handedly over here
fish sauce is a sick pick i would say
all right um i'm just looking through it
what do you expect of blitz js in the in
the coming years
uh we'll see
um uh i don't know it's gonna have a
tough time because i think as somebody
who's used like full stack frameworks uh
they it takes a lot for them to like
really take off and blitz js is on top
of next.js so at least has that going
for it where it's like alright this is
like nextgs with prism and or prisma and
all this other stuff right
and that's cool to me but like
i feel like it will have a hard time
getting
getting people to really latch on to it
and building a community but i think
it's cool and i think it's worth doing
i like this one what's the first node
module you install in a brand new react
project besides react itself
rudder
for me it's usually next js if it's
multi-page or parcel
if it is just a single little one-off
app
and because parcel will bundle it all
for you which is
kind of cool
i like that that was a good question
thoughts on using languages other than
js or ts with react like kotlin for
example i think it's neat um i've kind
of looked into some of this myself
lately but uh thoughts about using it
i'm not good at any other language if
we're being entirely honest so um
yeah js and ts for me all the way right
now but yeah you know i'm learning i'm
learning rust but i'm not going to be
super effective with it you know yeah i
don't i don't
have all the time in the world to learn
other languages although they probably
expand my horizons but there's literally
nothing wrong with just
spending all of your time in javascript
all right let's last one right here is
do you have any approach for optimizing
high-res images that are stored in your
back end like s3 for a gatsby website
we're talking about this on twitter
today um
and uh there's a lot of services that
will slurp up your image transform it on
demand and return it cloudnary imagex
sanity does it um whatnot
those are like yeah i think making your
own is is
what i need to do because i always i
love that approach on demand rather than
doing the gatsby build especially if
it's uh
if it's a remote image next js image
component does it with remote images
which is a killer feature
but not gatsby's
and uh but like i'm always like hesitant
to be like yeah just pay
this monthly cost for this service and
then the service will do it
because i do that but then also like
it sucks to have to tell someone just
pay for it yeah right right yeah
wouldn't it be cool to like
run it on like a serverless function or
something like that that'd be neat it'd
be cool if there was like a spin up
option where somebody had created like a
pre-configured one where you could just
like spin up your own platinary okay
yeah
you know
i think there i think that does exist um
it's just that like cloudinary has
four million features
and then you sometimes you use them like
the they even have like cpi like if you
wanted to sepia tone your photos like
it's a digital camera from 2001 you
could make it like into a photo booth at
a western show at disneyland
that's a great idea oh all right i think
we should end it off there um thank you
everybody so much for tuning in that was
really fun we always like doing these
live ones it's a bummer we couldn't do
it in person um but hopefully next year
we get get the big shot in the arm and
we'll be able to to see you all in
person what about uh sick picks do we
want to do some sick kicks before we
bounce off sick pics
quick picks we pick things that are sick
i i was just telling less i'm overflow
with with sick pics over here so uh well
west goes and uh hunts for his i'm gonna
pull up mine here sick picks my sick pic
the thing that i think is sick and this
is going to be a very special one this
is the coolest little extension i've
ever done used and it's called color
conversion color
this is a vs code extension and so i
i'll post it real quick here um
find the actual links page so i've been
um
personally dealing with a lot of like
moving colors to hsl hsla doing a lot of
variable work there and i found this
really neat extension for vs code that
allows me to
uh convert colors from it hex to hsla
and it um is so dang fast because you
just basically highlight your your color
string your hex value you say go turns
it to hsla again i'll post it in the
chat here i'm like trying to google it
while i'm uh talking about it but
it's really nice to not have to leave
your editor or whatever just toggle
through different types of color
conversions and this thing's been saving
me some serious time
i'm going to stick pick
a
lock picking kit um so i we have this
like vintage gumball machine in our
house and we bought it years ago and we
every now and then we put some candy in
it for the kids and they get a penny and
they turn it and they get like a couple
of um smarties that come out and uh it's
getting full of money and we don't have
the key we have the key to put the candy
in but we don't have the key to get the
money out and it's getting full so i
i i told kaitlyn i was like oh i'll i'll
learn to pick locks um so i bought
this
is uh it's an acrylic lock so it's
see-through and you can see
all of the pins in the lock so you can
see what you're doing
and then you can it comes with a whole
bunch of different picks
i'm trying to pick i did it
i did it on camera um so it's a super
cheap lock that's why it's so easy to
pick the real real locks are a lot
harder than that but um it's cool
because you can see what it's doing um
and how locks actually work um and that
just is so helpful to understand like
when you are picking a real lock what
are you trying to do right now you're
not just jamming this pick in there and
it came lining up the chamber came with
a whole bunch of
a whole bunch of different types of
picks and i i watched lock picking
lawyer on youtube so uh
yeah so much lock picking trying to lock
pick one of our doors and the door was
locked it was and it was like a super
fancy slang lock or whatever schlog yeah
not a slang slog
i was a slang in my slang and i could
not get the thing open obviously and
then i had a lockpicker come over and
need to use like a whole like big rig
machine to get it open so i didn't feel
too bad about myself after that
awesome um shameless plugs westboss.com
forward slash courses is the list of all
of my courses you can use syntax for 10
bucks off
and also mostly plug levelup
tutorials.com
sign up to become a pro and you'll get
access to 12 new tutorial series for the
entire year as well as the entire back
catalog of thousands of video tutorials
so check it out leveluptutorials.com
all right thanks so much to react on for
having us thanks everybody in the chat
that was super fun make sure you
subscribe to our podcast syntax.fm um
and in whatever podcast player you are
using and leave us a review
positive review and say nice things
about us too that'd be cool
peace
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you